Kevin McCarthy
is an epic loser
Kevin McCarthy is a historic loser
he has lost now 11 votes and right now I
have in front of me the the C-SPAN live
they are voting to go home
right now it's tied yays and nays
207-207 to leave and go home for the
night ah come on man it was funny
because at first they were like motion
to adjourn and then everyone's like no
and then they're like yeah and then the
clerk goes the nose have it and they're
like No And so they they called for the
actual vote tally right now the yeas
have just taken the lead they're gonna
go home ladies and gentlemen but this is
huge Kevin McCarthy has lost 11 times it
has not been uh this has not happened
since 1856.
that one I think took like 133 votes or
something you know this one around 11.
we'll see how long it goes but uh Matt
Gates stood up and nominated Donald
Trump whose name actually appeared in
the vote you'll love to see it so we're
going to talk about that and I've got a
bunch of other stories too we got uh
some some interesting cultural stuff
one uh more U-Haul trucks left
California than any other state you love
to see it there was a hoax tweet going
around from a doctor claiming to have
been like happy about you know dying
from the vaccine or something it's not
true so we'll talk about that uh there's
a truce Putin's calling for a true say
there's some good news and then a lot of
people are asking why I purchased uh a
certain skateboard truck company hey hey
I announced the logo for my new
skateboard company just so happens to be
this like Circle Cross thing and uh well
I'll I'll just I won't even I want to
beat around the bush so independent
skateboard a truck company had a symbol
a logo for decades that looked like an
iron cross they got canceled and accused
of being racist so they dropped their
iconic logo they no longer use it they
removed it from their products there's a
company been around for nearly 50 years
okay I'll take it you know you guys well
you don't want to use it because you
could be racist so you know we're going
to launch our own company we're going to
use that logo because they don't they
don't want to use it I I this is great
this is great news they don't want to be
called racist I don't care and I'm I
don't I don't I don't care for wokeness
and woke people so I will get to use a
50 year old iconic image that they don't
want anymore yeah talk about how so
we'll talk about that uh before we get
started my friends head over to
timcast.com become a member in order to
support our work directly click that
join us button a lot of stuff is in the
works we're going to be launching a long
Morning Show because I just felt like
doing it
five hour probably tomorrow we're just
gonna go live for like five hours and
then in between that as we're just
chilling and going through the news I'm
gonna record my normal morning monologue
segments and upload them while we're
live because it just sounds really fun
to do and then actually we're building a
studio out for this new show I talked to
Phil Labonte today he says he's down to
be involved I'm super excited for this
it won't be exactly the same as IRL
because this is a guest we have a guest
come out we talk topical news but it's
just going to be a live stream and then
we'll figure out how it goes and I think
it'll be a lot of fun so become a member
at timcast.com to support our work smash
that like button uh subscribe to this
YouTube channel joining us today to talk
about all of this and so much more is
Andrew Meyer yeah all right who are you
Andrew Meyer I think I'm probably best
known uh for being the infamous don't
tase me bro a few years ago at the
University of Florida
thank you questioning questioning
Senator Kerry I'm also the former
editor-in-chief of we are change for
this guy Luke Gronkowski and I'm a
right-wing entrepreneur I just launched
the first right-wing video game ever at
writtenhousegame.com where you've got
banned though right well they banned
mint chip mint chip is the CEO of mid
Studios they suspended him for putting
out a tweet talking about the game and
then they suspended me actually
for the second time they suspended me
for uh being a Jew that was in support
of yay that's why I was suspended this
under Elon and so what yeah I'm an
orthodox Jew I like yay I think that he
has uh very interesting things to say
and uh they suspended me for putting out
a tweet in support of him I was first
suspended under uh the old Jack Dorsey
Administration uh for pointing out the
game yes the uh Dorsey regime without uh
Ali Alexander stopped the steal in 2018
that we wouldn't have the governor of
Florida Ron DeSantis that it would have
been Andrew Gillum who was caught doing
you know meth in a motel with a
this is a family-friendly show right out
of the night yeah
man of the night thanks for keeping me
up again and you got a book no taste me
bro yeah I actually talk about that uh
don't tase me bro real questions fake
news and my life is a meme I go all the
way from the story of you know getting
tasered and all of that all the way up
to 2018 uh my my time working with Luke
my time covering stories like the 2018
stop to steal and honestly not to toot
my own horn but just legitimately this
is an incredibly well written book other
people besides me have said that I'm the
best writer on the right wing take it
for what it's worth it's an incredible
read uh it's on my website the
andrewmeyer.com right on man thanks for
joining us should be fun we also got
Luke hanging out if you're don't tase me
bro um don't tax me bro thank you so
much for coming on Andrew uh I think
it's also fair to say that some people
are dealing with mass formation
psychosis if you don't know what it is I
think you're dealing with it and if you
want to help warn people about this
dangerous mind virus you can on the best
political shirts dot com and by doing so
you also support me and my efforts here
thank you so much for having me Andrew
thanks for coming on long history
there's a lot of things we can unpack
here it's going to be a fun show I'm
really looking forward to getting into
it ma'am um well I'm Ian Crossland I'm
happy to be here let's Laurel let's go
Serge tell me about it hey I'm Serge
atsurf.com uh yeah ready for a show
it'll be fun here we go we got C-SPAN
pulled up right here ladies and
gentlemen as you are tuning into this
segment what can you see motion to
adjourn Republicans 219 Democrats 212
one Republican voted no but it looks
like the yeas have it and our lazy
members of Congress who did nothing but
sit there all day are voting to go home
without getting the job done
well I guess to be fair even those Brave
We the People votes of the Republican
party like Matt Gates Lauren bobert
Biggs Etc Cloud I think Clyde as well a
lot of people there's like 20 people 20
21. they're also voting to go home so
fine fine whatever I suppose if it means
more gridlock and nothing's happening I
guess the argument is uh it's a good
thing you know I don't know Luke seems
to be pretty it's a great thing it's
it's a beautiful thing because the
longer Congress fights with itself the
less they could fight against the
American people and you know 11 times
rookie numbers 1856 took 133 rounds of
voting over two months to elect
Nathaniel P Banks as Speaker of the
House again let's try to beat those
numbers here we're not far away we got
to keep pushing at it and I think the
longer Congress just gets in battle with
itself the more beautiful it is for
everyone else the more freedom we have
the more Liberty we have the less
government we have which I mean we're
all good I want to get this article up
real quick McCarthy nominated for 11th
ballot in the longest house Speaker
contest in 164 years loses again it
feels so good I think that the longer it
takes uh well how did you phrase it the
longer it takes the better off we are
yeah it kind of kind of exists until
there's a diminishing return because if
it happens for say seven years then yes
yes thank you you're speaking my lovely
cartels are running in the southern
border the cartels already are running
uh the the government especially in
Mexico and they're connected to the
intelligence agencies and if you look
how the cartels got their start they
wouldn't be as violent and as prolific
if it wasn't for American government and
and the Mexican Government running
protection records for them and giving
them a lot of money as nice as it is to
you know fantasize like oh what if the
government didn't work for two years the
next time it's time for Ukraine to get
their check so we can do money
laundering for everybody that works for
Northrop government in Congress you know
takes money from them the next time they
want to cut a check to Ukraine the
Democrats and Republicans will do a deal
so I'm enjoying this time it's a lot of
fun but we have to acknowledge the
Democrats and the Republicans they're on
the same side of every major issue and
they all want the money at the end of
the day that's why I'm wondering if you
think there's any value to it if it
keeps being gridlocked and they keep
they can't figure it out at some point
should it go to a general election like
we're voting for our president we're
voting for our speaker it doesn't have
to be a congress person it Trump
shouldn't be a congressperson to some
American that wants to step up and run
and do the job it could be anybody
they've officially adjourned they're all
going home
they're going to come back on January
6th and I wonder what tomorrow is going
to be like January 6th huh yeah January
6th it's a historic day that's like
that's like Democrats 9 11. is it yeah I
think some I think some uh you know
Windows got broken that day right right
a guy with horns walked around I think a
police officer shot an innocent woman
too yeah that's true I think actually I
don't know yeah shot and killed her
January six it's so far this is the one
story that just shows how split the
country is if you're on the left some of
these people said things like January 6
is the new Pearl Harbor oh yeah that's
how crazy they are worse than 9 11. but
then on the right you have people saying
this is the new July 4th like we're
gonna celebrate we're gonna have a good
time that's that's that's also very dumb
I mean I think if people want to
celebrate it I roll my eyes at it the
people who are saying it's like Pearl
Harbor that's like oh come on yeah I can
get why people are like there were
people cheering for January 6 but I'm
like you guys you gotta understand
it's one thing when people stand defiant
and like like this Matt Gates is like
we're blocking Kevin McCarthy this is a
tangible political conflict it's like
what I mean to say is there's actually
repercussions for what's happening right
now January 6 like nothing happened
Windows got broken people got people got
hurt Trump Sports got hurt there was no
political gain it actually just
benefited the machine that's why I'm
like that the whole thing was dumb one
of the things that nobody's talking
about is the pipe bombs on January 5th
you know the FBI discovered these pipe
bombs that were planted on January 5th
and right now Jacob wool is putting out
information that the government is
interested in like wait okay fine you're
investigating the story so we're going
to look into it too as to where these
pipe bombs actually came from they're
finally looking into it thanks to
Independent journalists like Jacob wall
and it's just amazing how many people
are still locked up in a gulag in DC for
what for going on a self-guided tour the
government let them in they wave them in
the videos are there them waving them in
let's let's make I I like the Nuance a
lot of people walked around they walked
in from the back entrance where the cops
wave them in and open the door and
because of this there was a direct
acquittal I think more than one there
was a direct acquittal of a guy in all
charges because there's a video showing
the cops waving him in another guy got
charges dropped but was still charged
for other reasons they were because like
he still ended up doing something that
was criminal but the trespass was like
no the cops did wave them in what
happens is people the staunch people on
the right side all the cops let them in
well there were there were people
fighting on one side smashing into cops
and fighting their way on on the other
side the cops opened the door both
things happened you know like the riot
was bad the violence was bad but most of
the people who were walking around they
had the doors open for them the people
who were fighting with cops were blocked
and struggled to get in it's also
interesting to see that the FBI a couple
days ago announced that they're going to
be doubling the reward money for
information that's going to lead to the
arrest of the pipe bomber uh that of
course laid the these pipe bombs on
January 5th very strange that this guy's
not caught here there's a lot of
involvement with the intelligence agents
here's here that of course it's still
being kept away from the general public
but in the new 1.7 trillion dollar uh
Omnibus Bill that was just passed there
was a provision there that's going to
double the doj funding when it comes to
Prosecuting people for January 6th and
it looks like they're going to try to
arrest double the amount of people that
they already have for the events that of
course happen on that particular day so
it looks like this is something that's
not going to be ending very soon I think
we need the tapes released I think this
is also one of the things that's being
negotiated right now with Kevin McCarthy
as even Tucker Carlson on Fox News came
out a couple days ago and said hey if
Kevin McCarthy releases the January 6
tapes then people will back him and
support him and vote him for speaker of
the house this is what according to
Tucker Carlson is being debated right
now at the house and is one of the key
Provisions behind keeping Uh Kevin
McCarthy in that position of power what
takes the January six tapes of exactly
what happened there and then all the
information that came forward there's
still a lot of surveillance footage that
is being kept away from the general
public there's a lot of videos there's a
lot of evidence still that the American
people have not seen that would probably
paint a a picture of of what happened
there in more detail than what we
already know I ran a poll in the chat is
it funny that McCarthy lost 11 times 95
yes I voted yes yes it is funny it's
funny it's funny strange Maybe funny
funny ha ha I don't like these people uh
Luke makes a really good point there's
there's countless hours of evidence from
January 6th that actually I'll I'll
throw it back to Ian's point the other
day that when you hit the nail on that
with the hammer saying sometimes no
investigation is better than
investigation because if McCarthy does a
sham investigation with a limited budget
it will convince people that that was a
real investigation they'll say look we
investigated all that stuff we found
nothing it's like you found nothing
because you gave him 10 grand like you
need a speaker who's going to go in and
say we're going to get a legitimate
hearing a legitimate commission with
real money behind this otherwise you get
McCarthy and I I think you were right
when you said that I think you want
independent commissions looking into it
too however who's going to appoint the
independent commission who are they who
is their father who's their second
cousin who are the who's paying them you
know I don't know but the idea that the
government would investigate itself
always makes I mean they have before
let's let's have some Nuance here
because I I agree in your in your
sentiment and and probably said that
they're exact words before but when it
came to the church commissions we found
out a lot that we would have never found
out if it wasn't for uh you know Brave
members of of Congress coming forward
and saying hey let's really look at what
the intelligence agencies are doing here
and then we found out a lot of their
bigger secrets and a lot of how they
were manipulating the corporate media
when it came to the consensus of our
society so I I I'm I'm on the other side
here I want more investigations I want
the government investigating itself I
want the government fighting itself I
want the government spending time
looking at each other rather than
looking at the American people uh on
average Congress passes about 85 bills
in a year hopefully we could stop that
number and make sure that they pass less
bills with this deadlock and one could
only dream right guys what do you know
about the lead up to the church
commissioner are you familiar with how
they got that going no I I do not I just
know that it was it was uh eye-opening
commission investigation and and
Congressional hearings that were
absolutely game changing when it came to
actually seeing what was happening
inside of the United States and just how
far and just how unaccountable some of
these intelligence agencies have gone
straight away from their original
purposes of fighting uh actual evil it
looks like it was called The Church
committee was like the the general term
but it was really called the United
States Senate select committee to study
governmental operations with respect to
intelligence activities was the actual
committee's name uh started in 1975 and
investigated the CIA and NSA what else I
actually wrote about it in my book
what'd you write about well just the
fact that they have people embedded
across the news media like the New York
Times Time Magazine all of these
different institutions admittedly had
CIA operatives embedded within them so
when you're watching corporate media if
you're not watching something
independent you're basically watching
the CIA giving talking points to people
that just repeat whatever they tell them
let me let me tell you how it works
you get 20 something out of college
journalists they're making a garbage
salary for a digital rag
when all of a sudden they get this big
story
CIA Source says Donald Trump bad man
and then everyone sees this small story
all these other outlets New York Times
Atlantic Etc Washington Post and they're
like whoa whoa whoa is this legit they
reach out to the editors and they're
like yup we have a legitimate Source
we've vetted this and they go this is a
huge story
this now young person is getting their
names set everywhere how do they get the
source and intelligence agencies how do
they get this all that information more
stories come out more stories come out
eventually companies come and say you
got good sources man come work for us
we'll give you double the salary then
they start getting mentioned then they
start getting asked to come on TV now
they're on TV saying our sources and the
intelligence agencies are saying these
things and they're like wow
because the intelligence agencies select
someone
feed them stories because they know a
young desperate journalist will run
whatever they say because it'll build
their career for them let's call what it
is grooming
young people to become journalists yes
that's a 20 right there that's one way
that they're doing it uh in other ways
they just have you know see how many
employees also work as the editors and
decide what story gets published and
doesn't get published and uh yeah I mean
both ways are true and um I think it was
uh what was his name a famous German
journalist that actually blew the
whistle about how the intelligence
agencies were coming to him with free
written stories that he literally just
had to put his name on he also uh died
suddenly of a heart attack a couple
years ago as well what was his full name
I think you remember everybody I
literally have that in my book too I was
looking for it yes yes yes
award-winning famous German German
mainstream corporate journalist just
came out and said hey most of my top
stories is weren't even written by me
they were written by the intelligence
agencies and I just put my name on free
money and no work wow you find the right
person who's got no Scruples and deal
and no soul have you guys ever discussed
on this show where the origin of the
term fake news comes from uh yes it
comes from a think tank that uh Eric
Schmidt financed with Hillary Clinton uh
uh during the 2016 presidential election
the first Washington I actually
confronted Eric Schmidt on this I was
like Eric Schmidt you were a part and
and finally raise the money for this
Ting tank that originally created this
term and then weaponized it against your
political opposition when you were
working and campaigning for with Hillary
Clinton and he told me some very bad
words uh you can still see that video on
YouTube I told you some bad words he
said some bad words what were you saying
the first Washington Post story that
dropped the term fake news before Trump
then took that term and stuck it right
on CNN and all the actual fake news
amazing the first story on the in the
Washington Post calling people fake news
it was talking about we are change and
about 100 different other media Outlets
we are the origins of fake news my
friend well they used it against us I
know they weaponized it you should
clarify that statement oh excuse me yeah
that sounds a little bad out of context
right but them trying to come after us
and label us with what they are which is
what they always do yeah like accuse
your enemies of what you were doing they
put out the fake news so they want to
call Independent journalists legitimate
people they want to call us fake news so
the origin of that term is them trying
to vilify us demonize us thank God Trump
took that term and stuck it right on
that it's very much the modern
conspiracy theory term the term
conspiracy theories invented from what
I've heard by the CIA to make people
that were saying that Kennedy was killed
by more than just Oswald there was
something they were saying there is a
conspiracy out there to say no you're
just a conspiracy theorist you're just
theorizing about conspiracies when in
fact they were conspiring at least
allegedly it just came out the CIA was
involved according to Tucker Carlson he
had some evidence I didn't see the
episode but uh Tucker actually I got I
gotta give a shout at sucker because I
got the sweet Tucker Carlson says dan
krencha is a committed neoliberal he's a
tool of of his donors he's hawkish on
Ukraine's border but indifferent to ours
and Dan Crenshaw knows that Kevin
McCarthy is the least conservative
speaker he is likely to get ever and by
the way he did call people terrorists I
listen to the video yeah it could be
taken out of context because if you
listen we should maybe listen to that
clip if you guys have it um but he said
he can't let the terror you can't let
the terrorists what he was doing was it
was like that was the Mantra that he was
repeating like a military Doctrine like
you don't you don't negotiate with
terrorists kind of thing you just like
plugged in a mantra so it was kind of
like he wasn't saying there they are
literal terrorists but he used that
Doctrine so you could see how people
will think he is Fox News called them
insurrectionists did you did you see the
Fox News anchors they really are they
saying the people not voting for Kevin
McCarthy insurrectionist I want to pull
up this clip from Michael Knowles now I
don't normally play clips from other
people's show but a lot of people are
shouting out that Lauren bobert appeared
on Michael Knowles's show and so I don't
want to piggyback their content but guys
you know this is big so shout out to
Michael Knowles and I want to play this
uh statement from from Lauren Boberg EOP
might be able to figure out people are
saying that once they heard Lauren
bobert lay this out they really went
hard against McCarthy figure out if they
had an ounce of self-awareness but they
don't so instead they're blaming Lauren
bobert we have Lauren on the call Lauren
thank you so much I know you're very
very busy right now uh but thank you for
making time to come on the show
absolutely thanks so much for having me
on Michael so Lauren where does it all
stand we've given a recap of of the the
speaker fight through last night on the
show Kevin McCarthy lost three rounds of
voting two days ago he loses three
rounds of voting yesterday you and those
terrible evil House Freedom caucus
Republicans you're you're not budging
here so what happens
well let's begin at where it started
this started in the summer we wanted to
handle this privately
um and and have a solution before
January 3rd these negotiations began in
the summer and they were dismissed
because Kevin McCarthy thought he was
going to have this massive Red Wave and
our votes did not matter when he saw
that the 300 million dollars that he
raised did not produce the red wave that
he promised he realized quickly he's
going to need our votes and so some
concessions
um were were put into play it was very
difficult to get them into play it was
difficult to get them approved with our
rules process the Way Washington D.C
operates and functions we want to
fundamentally change this town it is
broken it is less popular with the
American people than cockroaches so we
have to get something right here and we
cannot go along with the status quo well
on January 2nd um two of my fellow
colleagues and myself Matt Gates Scott
Perry we walked into
leader McCarthy's office after whipping
votes all day long and handed him 218
votes we said here it is let's seal the
deal here's some common sense issues
that you can put forward some promises
that you can make single member motion
to vacate so there is accountability on
the third in line to the presidency of
the United States you cannot demand more
responsibility and follow Nancy Pelosi's
precedence of less accountability so
this is our check and balance on the
speaker and that was a priority for me
personally certainly and for many others
but then things like bring the Texas
border plan to the floor for a vote
bring a term limits Bill to the floor
for a vote any member who wants to
reduce spending in an amendment will
make that amendment in order so we can
bring it to the floor and have a vote
earmarks bring them to the the floor oh
no we got an ad Capital Brave bro we do
use Brave we do actually you got an ad
on that yeah we can skip it sorry
Michael here we go we're back a vote
this is spending money that we do not
have so let's at least have a vote on it
instead of packing it into a bill where
we have no option to either swallow the
whole thing or say no way
um these are things that we presented to
him he uh solicited a list from us of
committee assignments all members
provide committee assignment requests we
know where our talents and skills are
are best utilized I wanna I wanna point
out real quick though I think what's big
here is she mentioned McCarthy thought
he was going to get a red wave which
meant he didn't need to actually go to
the freedom caucus for anything because
he wouldn't need their votes he thought
they were probably going to have what
like 240 seats
and then when they realized it wasn't
manifesting it's like uh oh so this guy
it sounds like really McCarthy did it to
himself and we provided that list
um Kevin McCarthy made a great argument
saying listen the people in this group
only want two committees I need you
spread out I want you to have more
influence and we agreed with that and we
said you know this is a time constraint
on many of the members that's a lot of
responsibility a lot of pressure but
we're willing to take that sacrifice and
have these committee assignments that
bear more pressure and so we provided
that to him and then January 2nd when
all of that was laid on the table
Kevin McCarthy laughed us out of the
room said that it was a selfish wish
wish list and would not take the deal
well now here we stand Michael I no
longer have those 218 votes to provide
to Kevin McCarthy so it doesn't matter
if I go to the floor today and vote for
Kevin McCarthy because there are now
more than ever votes that he does not
have to get to that speakership this is
very important to know he walked out of
that meeting and lied about what we
requested trust is absolutely broken if
there were if there was any to begin
with and this is a huge problem we want
unity in the Republican party and I
believe now is the time to start
seriously considering consensus
candidates who will unify the Republican
party so we can get to work for the
American people so Byron Donald is that
guy yep why do you think I just like his
personality he's six two two sixty five
man that did you see that interview
where they're like what do you think
about them threatening something
something and you he's like 306 to 260.
I'm not afraid of that he's like I'm not
scared yeah they're Italian because they
were using those words like threaten and
are you gonna fight on the floor of
Congress are you gonna fight for you and
he's like yo and he just turned around
on an actual fight like they're not
actually gonna fight they're not
actually threatening each other just
because someone might lose their job you
know because you could argue getting
your your income taken away could be a
form of life-threatening uh that was
that was a Chad Alpha statement when he
just smiled and said I'm six to 265 I'm
not worried Byron come on in man I want
to get Lauren in here too these guys are
close by I think it might be even a
weekend if you guys are up for a weekend
we could go down there or something but
I want to kind of amplify the messages
are you about to say something yeah just
that I'm glad the Patriots uh in the
Republican Party are holding out people
right very good people like say his name
again people like Ali Alexander have
been enduring lawfare from the January 6
committee for like two years now they
made him spend his life savings they
made him defend himself for eight hours
and if he said one word wrong they would
have tried to throw him in prison like
they did to Roger Stone so the fact that
this January 6 committee exists it's
been pushing lies it's been used as
lawfare to try and decapitate the
strongest political leaders on the right
now that we have the house we but now
that the Republicans have the house they
should use the January 6 committee and
actually do something for the Patriots
for their constituents and go and
investigate what have the Democrats been
doing with this committee what happened
on January 5th was this whole thing some
sort of psyop that was ginned up by the
intelligence agencies because it looked
like they got a lot going on there and
revolver news has had a lot of reporting
about that Ray apps with the transcripts
that got released we absolutely need to
see them go after that that's right
maybe I want it's the weirdest thing
when uh the transcript comes out and
there's a quote from Ray app saying that
he orchestrated he texted someone saying
that and then kinsinger tweeted out that
it was completely untrue it is shocking
to me that there can be a transcript you
can read and these people are just
smiling like never happened but there
are people stupid enough to believe him
he's on video cheering this whole thing
on orchestrating it and then another
question is who opened those doors those
magnetic doors that couldn't be opened
by humans but were open from the inside
those are important questions that we
deserve to know what actually happened
here who opened those doors why was
security called off what in the world
was going on here with Ray apps there's
a lot of questions I think those
questions deserve to be answered and the
January 6th commission was is not
answering them the video of them opening
the doors you're talking about is really
the magnetic doors yeah it's from inside
the building and use there's people
outside yelling and then someone walk
box up to the magnetic door sealed doors
they're barred shut they look back and
like point up at someone and then the
doors are magnetically unlocked and
opened and all these people start
pouring in who opened the door who
verified the door being able to push the
I want to know too it's crazy video
because someone look for all we know
someone broke into the security booth
and hit the button maybe okay let's
let's get that video released so we can
figure out what's going on I thought
that would have been a talking point by
the corporate media and the Democrats
look at these they had Insider knowledge
they knew what their door they did they
ran dry drills they they knew where the
button was we haven't had any of that
but they would have sensationalized it
to the highest degree that they could
sorry Ian I was just thinking about If
there really was like real violent uh
damage done that day like if people went
in with weapons and started shooting the
the cops in the building would have
killed a bunch of people and then put a
ton of people in prison and it would
have been a really big deal but it was
just like a guy in a viking suit
laughing as people around them were like
yeah dude I mean I'm not saying for
there was violence going on wasn't
wasn't that guy like telling a cop who
was like sorry yeah we'll get out of
here man that's really disrespectful
Jason rink is directing a film about him
called Q sent me and he's got hours of
interviews with uh the Q Shaman and
basically the guy is a well-meaning dude
that walked in you know he was allowed
into the building and they're treating
him like he's Osama Bin Laden it's the
craziest thing in the world wasn't he on
mushrooms
are you confusing with me is everything
they just legalize mushrooms in Oregon
first time first state it's completely
recreationally legal now I just saw
Dennis McKenna tweeted it out anyway
let's get back to I don't know if he was
on mushrooms or not I wouldn't be
surprised that's the kind of thing
people have done on when you're dosing
hard I've seen that trip yeah a lot of
people have pointed out that hearing
Lauren bobert on Michael Knowles's show
made them really just anti-mccarthy and
I I agree you know we we don't think
everything about it so you should
definitely check out Michael knows
interview with her I don't want to you
know just ride the whole the whole
segment but uh I I agree
I had heard rumors about it but the the
main point is that
they had an opportunity in the summer to
do a deal
McCarthy thought he wouldn't need it the
Republicans performed terribly for a
variety of reasons now he's desperate
and he can't get it good you reap what
you sow man if we can't if they can't I
say we but it's them unfortunately
they're representing we the people uh if
we can't get to a consensus about who is
are we just going to sit here for the
next six seven eight weeks and every
show is just like the house is there
again watch him go home for dinner at
eight right before we need popcorn first
of all right and uh yeah hell yeah why
not
yeah I call it life and death last night
people were like oh haha Ian called this
life and death but I mean it's the it's
the the leadership of the most powerful
military on Earth is now finding itself
in a gridlock pattern which is I'm
chilling I'm chilling I mean American
citizens are pretty much in the same
state they were last week I think the
bigger issue is that tomorrow everyone's
like I'm over it dude we get it Kevin
McCarthy can't win why do they keep
doing this you know I get it the
alternative is what emotion to adjourn
that's not gonna work I I think if I
would like can we get a motion to never
be allowed to a journal until this is
resolved that's what I'd vote for I beg
no one's leaving their job is basically
to sit around as it is is like the
easiest look right now there's some dude
loading bags into a truck loading boxes
into a Truck heavy lifting covered in
sweat his back is hurting and is getting
paid less than these people to sit
around and complain about each other
this is why I'm afraid or concerned
about leaving it up to the con to the
house to find their own speaker because
it they are going to break each other's
will and then just browbeat people down
to like okay fine I don't care anymore
take it take whoever you want that's not
the way you elect leadership we need the
people deciding who is going to be the
voice of that of that movement well I'll
say it's tough for us to decide who's
going to be be the voice of that
movement I'm I'm living in Arizona I
love Arizona I think it's the greatest
state in the country and right now I was
there it took three hours for me to vote
I watched a ton of people get out of
line they had all kinds of malfunctions
where the voting machines were not
taking you know the the you know 19
inches instead of 20 is what they said
yeah the bat was rejecting the the
machine was rejecting the ballot they
were rejecting the ballots and the
tabulators and they had a two-day trial
if you watch that trial Shane Cashman
timcast.com wrote an incredible article
about it yeah Shane's great Shane's a
great I want to meet Shane he's cool
yeah he wrote him cooler after you meet
him his article was really good and it
was not assertive he didn't come out and
say this definitively was this he said
here's the evidence presented here's
what I experienced the media wasn't even
talking about the evidence that the
Witnesses were presenting it's crazy so
the judge in that case I don't know how
the judge got to the conclusion after
those two days when every Republican
Witness
said factually here is what happened
like this is against the law this is
crazy there's no chain of custody and
then the Democrat witnesses there the
Democrat lawyers are flustered it's
crazy and then to dismiss that case well
I'll put I'll put it very lightly
there are bad judges who make bad
rulings
if if however you want to interpret that
Kerry likes appealing so the interesting
thing is that moving forward
I don't know it too much about it but
I'm very optimistic my understanding is
that the argument made by Kerry Lake's
legal team
is based on precedent set by the same
court she's now petitioning so it would
be really really I think they planned
this like I I like you you can't imagine
that Kerry Lake's legal team after
seeing everything they've seen did not
have a plan in place it would be really
weird if the Arizona I think they're
going to the Arizona Supreme Court
rejected its own precedence and said no
actually we changed our mind on it would
it would just be like it's kind of
setting them up you know it'd be a
little bit like 2020 and repeat the fact
that not a single Supreme Court case was
held in 2020 was just insane I mean it's
it's not crazy precedent Bush V Gore we
saw it in 2000 that they will hear a
case okay what's going on with the
elections but we didn't even get to hear
a case in 2020 and for the Arizona
Supreme Court if they don't have the
courage to hear this case then I
question the legitimacy of our entire
country you can give a shout out to
Thomas and Alito who agreed to hear the
Texas VPN I think was Texas V
Pennsylvania and then you had uh you had
um Coney Barrett you had Kavanaugh who
said no he had Robert said no so I mean
look some of these are Trump's Trump's
appointees and they and and the issue is
when that suit happened and this is a
lawsuit it's an argument that never got
to happen okay it's questions about the
legality of voting procedure nothing to
do with fraud they called it a fraud
lawsuit over and over again the Press
because they were lying this was Texas
saying we don't think the procedure held
in the in the in the law by Pennsylvania
is in line with the Constitution uh
dictates and and the Supreme Court is
supposed to handle original jurisdiction
that is disputes between states Thomas
and Alito both agreed whether we want to
or not we are obligated to take up a
court case between states and then
everyone else just said we're not
getting anywhere near this and so now
you have people who are upset that these
questions didn't get resolved what ends
up happening Arizona and now you have
people whose confidence in the system is
shattered I have to wonder if that's
what they wanted
I have to say because you mentioned
Trump earlier these are Trump's justices
Trump listened to McConnell McConnell
picked the justices for him and Trump
has had track record of putting the
worst people around him picking the
worst people around him he endorsed
McCarthy for this uh speaker race that
we're all enjoying where McCarthy is
failing over and over and over again and
Trump you know for people I love him I
voted for him I I tried everything I
could to help get him in office both
times but I think he's retired and we
should want him to be retired because he
doesn't know how to put competent people
around him let me pull up this story
from timcast.com Matt Gates votes Trump
for house speaker and not just that he
stood up and nominated him and it was
the greatest thing look Trump's not
going to win but they act C-SPAN
actually added Trump's name to the vote
tally and there's like one vote from
Matt Gates
what was funny about this is not just
that is that he's sitting next to
Marjorie Taylor green when he's when
he's announcing this vote and she's
voting for McCarthy but back to what you
were saying Trump having been retired my
first question before we get into what
Trump is up to
would Trump at this point based on what
you said would Trump be if he could be
would he be a good speaker I don't think
Trump has any interest in being the
speaker but hold on I know I know that
my question is would we even want him to
be I would take him but is he a better
candidate than someone like uh Steve
scalise who's like a compromise
candidate I don't know because Trump
gives the establishment everything that
they want he's not the independent when
he said during the swamp he didn't do it
when he said build the wall he didn't do
it so why would we even want him at this
point he's not anti-establishment he's
establishment he's Paul McCarthy he's
promo If he if he did get in how much
you want to bet he'd be like Okay Kevin
what should I do
yeah he has I don't it probably doesn't
even know what the speaker of the house
is supposed to do at this point does he
have any idea what the speaker of the
house does I think I didn't ask him I
didn't Bannon say Trump should be
speaker as well
at this point look man a few months ago
I was like oh DeSantis maybe Trump now
I'm like the Santa's very heavy because
Trump seems to be just out of the game
like by choice like he's she's like I'm
chilling dude leave me alone that brings
me to an interesting question in the
Republican debates you're going to see
retired Trump not like strong 2015 Trump
but like retired Trump you saw his
inaugural his speech announcing his run
he looked pretty tired DeSantis who you
can watch his uh debate one for governor
he choked pretty hard like he didn't do
so well in those debates a little dry
he's a little dry tennis is a dry in
this you know not so charismatic and
then it's a fact yay is going to be in
those days yay is going to be in those
debates Bring It On do you think it's
really possible
the debates are are controlled by a
bureaucratic force of Democrats and
Republicans that kick out anyone from
the third party they only make sure that
their swamp candidates are pretty much
in there how would I don't I don't know
who is they who says
establishment Democrat and Republicans
that that run the presidential debate
committee which is a private
organization that pretty much is there
to kick anyone else out that isn't a
part of the swamp okay I'm sorry I
interrupted you that's a champion no
you're okay yeah is one of the most
charismatic people in human history like
him or not disagree with him or not he's
one of the most charismatic people in
human history I know that he's been
talking to Ali Alexander who's maybe the
smartest political strategist uh in the
country so the most charismatic guy with
the smartest political strategist in a
debate with retired Trump uh you know
not so strong DeSantis in a debate and
then the rest of the whatever
establishment candidates they roll
Pompeo you might see something very
surprising in those debates I don't
think Nikki Haley we gotta shout out
Shane Cashman again because he also
wrote the yay article and got to sit
down with yay people need to get this
when yay got up and left Shane Cashman
he's a huge fan of Kanye West as an
artist and and knows a lot about his
life and career and Shane went up to yay
and started talking to him and I here's
my opinion on what happened because I
don't want to speak for Shane or yay but
I think yay immediately recognized that
Shane actually knew what he was talking
about Shane was referencing things about
yay's career that he could see in what
was happening now one of the things he
mentioned was that yay has this Arc of
bombing with negative press and then
rising up really big even bigger and he
and and there's an element of maybe yay
is trying to do nuclear bad press as
part of some kind of strategy or
something but Shane talks to yay yay
immediately goes come with us fly out
and so we you know Shane didn't go but
but a few days later we're like bro like
go talk to these guys and then he
decided he was gonna go do it he got to
actually sit down with yay it's a really
really interesting article you need to
understand yay's strategy because we sit
here and we and we laugh about the
absurdity of his Alex Jones interview
but if this guy
has continually found a way to you know
dive and then re you know and then come
back like a phoenix yeah like I think
I think you'd be a fool to underestimate
a guy who was able to make himself a
billionaire whether it be Trump or yay
they made fun of look I I don't know I
think that Alex Jones interview was nuts
don't get me wrong but everybody made
fun of trump and I think you know one of
the things yea said to me was that Trump
opened the door and showed us how so I
wonder if he's actually doing something
I'm not saying he's going to win but I'm
saying when it comes to the debates I I
lean towards agreeing with you I don't I
don't know that's a tough call but he's
a charismatic powerful guy I think he
could find his way in I think your man
Shane Cashman hit on something because
I'm a Jew when I first watched The Alex
Jones interview with yay and he was um
saying positive things about the Nazis I
I really didn't like it I'm not gonna
lie like I did not enjoy it but then I
listened more and he was saying I love
everybody I love the doctor that killed
my mother I love Mao satung he was
trying to preach Christian values which
is that uh he loves everyone that's what
Ian was saying yeah he was saying the
same thing it was brute Lil Wayne did it
was Brute Force so it came off you know
with these little Clips to take it out
of context make him look like a psycho
but that's what happens erratically
honestly hold on to be fair in context
it made him look like a psych but not if
you listen to the whole interview
because what you're saying Andrew is
accurate he started to talk about all
the villains of history and how he has
love for these people even people that
have wronged him personally I haven't
heard the Mao stuff I I did hear him
just focus on that one leader in Germany
in 1930 to be honest with you did he say
Mal yeah he said Mao too okay I mean
it's a three-hour interview it's easy
not to see the whole thing this is some
so Shane released a clip where he brings
this up to yay and I think you should
listen to it and judge for yourself but
he said says it's interesting how you
say you like a bad person really like
someone one of the worst and that is the
only thing said but when you mention
that you love other people you love the
Jews you love other groups no one wants
to hear that portion of it and so it's
almost like
I guess the idea is kind of like Yay was
intentionally seeing how you would react
when he presented you with a positive
and a negative and then you only care
about the negative thing you said not
the positive weeds out oh we're gonna
say yeah weeds people out that are like
short-sighted I find but it also puts
you at a disadvantage emotionally for a
while after you do it because it angers
a lot of people but you do see the fools
the comedian Owen Benjamin uh I did a
debate with him a couple of years ago
and we were debating about Jews and he
said that you know Jews are like a
sacred cow you're not allowed to discuss
whether they're good or they're bad and
and I told him I don't want to be a
sacred cow I don't want my people to be
a sacred cow let's discuss the good and
the black in the community otherwise
you're stultifying the community it's
the only way to move things forward like
nobody nobody says how dare you discuss
if there's crime in the black community
because you look at the statistics okay
there's an issue how do we address it if
you look at my community there's way
more disproportionate of my people
involved in things like the negative
corporate media banking I I'm not trying
to sound anti-semitic I've been accused
of that somehow it's very crazy but it's
it's easy to look at my community and
say there's these problems and if you
don't let people discuss it it makes
people very hateful so I don't want
there to be any sacred cows and I think
one of the things yay was doing is
saying okay this is a sacred cow I'm not
allowed to say that I love the Nazis
well I love everyone I have Christian
values I love everyone and he's
slaughtering a negative sacred cow which
is Hitler is supposed to be so much
worse than Mao Mal killed way more
people Mal killed way more people it was
like 50 million or something like that
yeah the starvation killed more people
and people are allowed to wear communist
logos on their shirts that stuff's evil
too here's my thing about this we you
know I think in the 30 minutes that we
had with yay like we mentioned the Jon
Stewart thing Jon Stewart said exactly
what you did that if there are people
who are seeing a lot of Jewish people in
certain sectors Finance or media
whatever and anytime they try and bring
that up they're they're attacked then if
it's going to actually make things worse
yep and I agree with that my issue is
look before we went live yay was calm
and we talked about all of that I said
you know look but what about Elon Musk
Jeff Bezos Bill Gates and he was like
yeah well you know they work for Jewish
people don't they and blah blah and it
was very chill but then when we go live
all of a sudden he was very angry high
energy like saying that I was disrespect
like I'm gonna get a PJ if I'm getting
lectured like Lex Friedman and it was
like all of a sudden this calm
conversation we had had transformed into
something that felt totally fake and
then he gets out of here and a couple
hours later he got a private jet already
waiting for him at the airport which I
just don't see as being particularly
likely I so I I don't feel like it was
an honest interaction to be honest all
I'll say to that is that um one of the
the wisest sadiq's a righteous named
ravaslog said is that all you can really
choose in life is who you surround
yourself with and at the time that he
did the interview with you he had like
Milo in his corner and I don't have very
many nice things to say about Milo okay
I'm not a fan and Milo is not with you
anymore and Ali Alexander is and I I
have a lot of good things to say about
ali Alexander I've known him for years
and he's a positive force you can listen
to him
he espouses Christian values and lives
it more than just about anybody and
though I'm a Jew if this country doesn't
return to God this country will fall
look at Europe Europe is they always say
Europe is like 10 years ahead of us or
England's 10 years ahead of us England
is falling into the garbage because
those people are largely atheists and if
America doesn't return to being
Christian because it's not going to be a
Jewish Nation it's not going to be a
Muslim Nation if this doesn't become a
Christian Nation again this country is
not going to stand oh I'm sorry to
interrupt man what was it next thing
you're going to say it's just that yea
actually puts out Christian energy you
listen to Jesus's King that had
spiritual energy his album Jesus's King
was incredible it returned people to
Christ into God he needs he needs to
hang out with Shane Cashman
his article is incredible yeah his his
and and really we mean it and I think
Shane understands Kanye's career and
understands the christ-like stuff and I
think would be a positive influence to
get away from that weird stuff that he
did on Alex Jones something I was
learning while from what happened when
he was on the show and the whole Jewish
conversation around Kanye and everything
was uh that a lot of the people that
call themselves Jewish don't believe in
God at that point I'm like I don't I
question that you're even a Jew at that
point like you might be in Israelite
because you are derived from Jacob
Jacob's tribe Jacob is Israel Judah his
son
spawn the Jewish people but they it was
the god that was but but if not for God
they would not exist so like I just got
to say it's a semantic argument Jewish
religion Israelite by culture that's
what I'm proposing but you're just
you're just making a semantic argument I
don't think so because people call
themselves cultural Jews I get it you're
from the tribe of Judah but you're
really you're also from the tribe of
Israel like you are an Israelite there
are Jews uh in Israel that say what's
happening in America is like a second
Holocaust because there's so many Jews
that are becoming atheists and because
they don't uh care about anything about
the Torah they're willing to intermarry
to the point where their their
descendants are not going to be Jewish
so they say it's like a second Holocaust
because these people eventually you
could say that uh you could call it now
that they're not Jewish now but if if
they're atheist and they intermarry and
eventually their kids will not be Jewish
so that is the diminishment of the tribe
in the way in which Ian is describing it
but I will say that the problem with the
The Atheist Jews in this country is the
same problem with any other atheist if
you are disconnecting from God you're
not going to have truth in your life at
some point you can do great things in
this world but if you're not connected
to God at some point you're going to
fall I love Scott Adams I think Scott
Adams is one of the most incredible
commentators of our lifetimes how he
explained Trump to people but at a
certain point it's like his commentary
went a little Askew and I believe if he
were connected to God that would never
have happened I I don't mean the bogart
of my God no no I wanted to say it's
it's believing in something bigger than
yourself and whatever that means I see
what I see a lot of people is like I
don't care if you're an atheist I care
if you hold yourself above all others
and so we end up getting there's there's
a couple different ways to look at
atheism that we've seen there have been
moderate secular people who are good
people who are moral people who don't
want to infringe on anybody don't think
they're better than you they just don't
believe in God but now we're seeing a
lot of young people who are atheists and
think that's carte blanche to be
narcissists to be tests to be entitled
or to just inherently have those traits
within them because they don't think
there's anything else they're like well
there's no God it's only me then I'm the
only thing that matters everything is
totally I think part of why the Jews
were so successful as a as a as a
culture and as religion and as a faith
and as a people is because they follow
the tenets of God like you don't covet
your neighbor's wife you don't steal
people's stuff you don't murder people
you don't worship false Idols like you
don't money all this crap like the usury
thing is where I start to wonder these
people like fell away from the path and
then started provoking and and using the
other people as slave like usury was
punishable by death for a long time
insane amounts of Interest I I think the
family unit is also something worth
talking about since of course a lot of
religious Jewish people spend their
entire Friday night and Saturday night
together that's awesome that that is
that is a superpower that is helping
people connect with their their loved
ones with with their own you know with
their own people and and I think that
that truly is one of the more important
tenets especially when it comes to the
larger statistics to strong family units
to to a lot of success I'll tell you a
personal story I don't think I've told
this anywhere but when the Dante's me
bro thing happened my parents were
counseling me hey don't get expelled
from the University don't go like I
could have gone on every TV show in the
world and my parents wanted me to be
low-key don't get expelled from the
University don't go to trial with these
bogus criminal trials and I I wanted to
go on every show I wanted to go on Bill
O'Reilly and confront him for being such
a war Pig I wanted to go on Jon Stewart
and say how dare you call me a douchebag
you're a sellout I wanted to do all
these things but a voice came to me was
like honor your mother and your father
they really did not want me to go high
key with it and if I did I know I would
have become an egotistical monster I
never would have become a more refined
man and so what you were saying about
the the value in uh actually believing
in Torah or like the Jewish tradition
connect to God without that I'd be lost
and I wasn't even someone that was so
heavy believing in God it's just
something that that occurred to me so I
just feel like if you look at world
history Christianity did so much good in
the world it wiped out human sacrifice
and cannibalism off this continent so if
you're not if you have a nation totally
disconnected from God what does that
look like well I'll tell you we got this
article from SF Gate more U-Haul trucks
left California than any other state in
2022 and do you know why because there
is human excrement lettering the streets
in all of their major cities I don't
care if you're going to lasf Sacramento
whatever it's everywhere it's everywhere
Fresno it's Fresno oh it's bad have you
heard about the poop Department in San
Francisco yeah they have an app called
Snap crap
that's a real thing snap crap so this is
the point
uh snap crap on that was to warn people
of where the pope is
the health department go and clean it up
it's real snap crap snap crap but it
doesn't even matter because it's just
Brown like the map there's so many poop
notes placed it's just a brown splotch
over San Francisco this is what happens
with
too much government loss of family yeah
loss of family the issue isn't
necessarily governed but I don't
completely disagree with you if you have
people who are family oriented family
first if they have some kind of belief
in something Beyond them be it God or
otherwise like a moral sense which I do
think comes from God in a lot in a lot
of ways but I think there can be people
who are moral without believing in God
if if you have that then you have people
in government with Scruples you have a
cop who's like I can't give someone a
fake ticket a bogus ticket I can't
wrongly arrest this person that'd be
wrong I'll be punished God will be mad
at me my family will be mad at me my
community will be mad at me but now
because everyone is this I'm the only
one that matters you get bad cops you
get bad government you get poop all over
the streets you get people saying I
could solve the problem but I'd like to
campaign off of it to get reelected so I
won't I see some problems with like
honor thy mother and thy father which is
super important that's part of the tour
that's part of the Ten Commandments is
it not uh and then uh what happens is
people with bad parents or parents that
aren't there it's people that don't know
their dads like this is kind of an
endemic thing in our society how do you
honor someone that you hate that wronged
you that that set you in a path of
emptiness like how do you honor someone
like that that's why I always recommend
people listen to Jesse Lee Peterson
Jesse Lee Peterson says forgive your
mother because so many people had
mothers that didn't do right by them I
actually brought this book I didn't even
know how to talk about this specifically
but this is the Contin
um concept I brought this literally just
because it says that mothers that don't
constantly hold their babies it's like
the babies feel neglected and people
grow out without a sense of love and
that's people that have mothers that are
at least trying a little bit people
without parents at all or your mother
was abusive so that's going to screw you
up Jesse Lee Peterson says forgive your
mother it helps so many people like
forgive their mother return to their
father connect to God so I love Jesse
Lee Peterson for that and since I
brought him up uh he's uh in a
commercial I said I'm a right-wing
entrepreneur I'm putting out this stuff
Alpha jerky at bigclubusa.com and Jesse
Lee Peterson there's a hilarious
commercial that I that we put out with
uh Jesse Lee it's on uh Patriot Jay's uh
Twitter right now banned from Twitter by
the way patriotic Elon Musk restore
Patriot J restore Patriot Day today yo
that jerky's legit dude oh yeah it's the
only preservative and it is salt it's
salt no sugar and what water so this guy
Andrew is like I got I got something you
might want to check out I was like I
don't know man you think it's jerky and
I might look at it no no sugar no
garbage salt a brown pepper and beef so
this is what happens with good family
values you get the seed oils and the
garbage out of your food you don't buy a
U-Haul to flee California you move to
Florida or you live in Florida already
speaking of where you at now where are
you based out of Arizona it's the
greatest state but if we don't have a
miracle people please pray for Carrie
Lake's appeal I need that state to stay
red I don't want to live in a state
where some democrat Governors decides oh
guess what uh there's a new uh chicken
flu and everybody stay inside your house
or you get arrested those U-Hauls
leaving California are going to Arizona
in Texas it's a great state but don't
the article actually mentions that a lot
of people are moving to Texas oh wow and
the fact is the fastest growing state in
the United States is Florida but the
number one state that people are leaving
according to the latest data is New
Jersey Illinois New York and Connecticut
New Jersey let me let me tell you about
something about New Jersey we were there
for a little while
and I was actually really excited by the
idea I was like we can we can fix this
place we can we can build a culture here
New Jersey has a brain drain among the
Young no young person wants to live in
New Jersey so they leave right away and
this makes the state stagnant and bad
and then you get bad government and
problems which perpetuate the cycle the
worse the government gets the more
nobody wants to be there so I'm like we
should set something up here and then
start pushing back it's not possible I
just I just feel like you can't be done
so we left it's the epitome of like a
state being run by its capital or it's a
swap State it's like New York has at
least Upstate New York but Jersey
doesn't the whole thing is just a swamp
there's a reason we call it dirty Jersey
there's a reason the taxes are so high
there's a reason you can't defend
yourself it's it's an absolutely
horrible state that a lot of New Yorkers
who tapped out of New York City just
went to in order to get away from all
the yuppies and all the urban
professionals taking over uh what used
to be a great City New York City did you
go to Jersey much when you lived in New
York absolutely not are you kidding me
did you ever go to Manhattan or were you
just kind of a Borough guy sometimes it
depends I was mainly just in Brooklyn so
yeah a broken guy twice as both instead
of both it depends it was my accent was
worse before now it's I wish I could do
a video of like when it was yes my
earlier videos on my channel it's
horrible and I cringe watching it all
the time it's absolutely embarrassing
but uh yeah I got videos on my channel
from like 2008 to 2007 and it was Heavy
then yeah I'd be like you'd be like hey
Luke did you want the vanilla ice cream
or the chocolate both I'd be like
b-o-a-f both but I've been working on my
language
enough to believe this I don't know if
Luke gets enough credit for being the
legend I don't journalist that he is
this guy was confronting Larry
Silverstein uh Jacob Rothschild I
believe Eric Schmidt this guy he got his
own channel demonetized by yelling at
the CEO of Google this guy is one of
them
independent journalist in this era and I
just don't know if he gets enough credit
for that we broke the spirit cooking
story Cassandra Fairbanks on we are
change 2016 we helped swing that
election yep it was Cassandra Fairbanks
and you working as the top editors we
had a staff of like 30 people we were
releasing articles we broke that Spirit
cooking story uh and we were kicking
butt we were doing a lot of incredible
work but uh I made I made the mistake of
having
um uh left-wing people and right-wing
people and I said look let the best
ideas win we're gonna debate them if a
right-wing person puts out an article
you disagree with right at counter
argument and let's actually have this
debate on the platform it worked for a
while and then everyone started fighting
each other and then there was a Civil
War and it got bad and I'm like I just I
just gave up so but it was it was it was
the good old heydays of actual
journalism of actual investigations of
actually talking about the stories that
mattered and we had a full frontal
attack by the establishment by the court
media that went after us hardcore and I
mean I'm still I'm still keeping at it
but um those are different days so let
me ask you about Texas then do you think
the people leaving California are good
people do you think the people leaving
California are like based and they're
like I don't want to be here anymore
let's go to Texas I think they have to
be right but is it is it possible
they're also just like default liberals
who are like things are really bad let's
go vote for the same thing in Texas
locusts they're like locusts I think a
lot of these people they didn't learn a
thing they're just like hey like Tim
just said it's really bad here let's go
somewhere else and they don't learn why
is it bad remember that guy who was like
I vote Democrat but this is really bad
so I'm going to Florida where I'll keep
voting Democrat and it's like no no no
no no don't you get it I don't think so
I think looking at the the election
numbers especially from Florida we saw
that this biggest transplant movement
especially from New York City with
predominantly right-wingers we saw that
a lot of people are even estimating that
Lee zeldin could have won New York as
Governor if those people didn't flee to
Florida Florida became from came from a
purple state to a solid red state that
happened because the same people who
think the same way are moving to places
that they think they're going to be
respected
um and I think that's the majority of
people leaving California now the only
thing I'll say to whether Lee zeldin
could have won is there's a documentary
called kill chain this is on HBO and it
has people like Kamala Harris talking
about hacking elections and saying that
elections can be easily hacked so I
don't know if any amount of people not
fleeing to Florida would have fixed New
York and I have I have a book that I'm
putting out soon you'll see excerpts of
it on my sub stack that I just launched
the
andrewmeyer.substack.com but the book is
called blatant fraud the stealing of
Arizona and I get in depth of what's
going on in the just like HBO did just
like uh 20 years ago they had a movie
blackboxvoting.org and they talked about
what was going on with the George Bush
elections you know as I said to John
Kerry the voting machines counting
backwards so this stuff is not new let
me ask you
in all your wisdom how do we stop the
problem of poop in the streets of
California no no but as a more serious
take on the question if people are
fleeing it's because of things like that
and these problems is there is there
even a solution to it because I gotta be
honest what can the government do that
it can't that as it's already failed at
and then if you do nothing people will
just stay there and poop in the streets
it's all about the individual every
single person you have to you have to do
your utmost you better be praying to God
you can fast you can I recommend this
this I'm going to give you this by the
way Tim this is the Zohar I have one
really yeah what is it this is literally
the Holy Grail I kid you not like you
can look in the Catholic encyclopedia
what is the Holy Grail do some research
eventually you'll find this book this is
the soul of the Torah the soul of the
Bible and just having this is so much
light if enough people in the world have
just have this the Zohar I used to give
these out up and down the coast of
Florida because there used to be so many
hurricanes they started this project
give out the Zohar along the coast
Florida there was no hurricanes for a
decade not one and you could say oh well
that's just a coincidence but I could
tell you story after story after Story
literal Miracles with this book you
already have one I don't I don't care
somebody somebody came on the show
before and and give this one as well
dude I'll take it amazing yeah let's I
won't absorb I'll put it under my
pillows thank you yeah okay is it bound
backwards that's the first thing because
it's got It's got a Hebrew letters it's
got Aaron made oh it reads right to left
yeah but that has also has English in it
so you can learn and study and and this
is saying it uh foundational work in the
literature of Jewish mystical thought
known as Kabbalah yep and so the
Kabbalah is like the mystical nature of
Judaism there's four levels of Torah
study the deepest level the so the
secrets that's where you're studying
Kabbalah and the righteous say ravaslog
said in our generation we have to study
the secrets first if we don't study this
stuff it makes the Torah dry and on our
generation this is the lowest generation
of all time I think it's pretty obvious
uh we need the highest light so that's
that's why this book which used to be
buried for thousands this was buried
kept secret used to be you had to be 40
years old in a Jew and chosen by a
teacher and a man uh before you'd be
allowed to study this that there's
people that still believe this
prohibition is exists today it was
overturned 500 years ago by
avrahamasalai but this stuff was Kept
Secret and now this light is available
for Our Generation because our
generation is so low is it like sacred
geometry and chakras unload like fixing
your body posture so you can get in
touch with God fasting and things like
that Gematria definitely like if you
read the Zohar you will find some things
that make your your head uh
explode I don't know you'll be very
excited if you like Gematria and you
start reading the Zohar you'll be very
excited well in on that note let's go to
a very similar story in fact I mean
actually it's not similar at all but
just because I really want to talk about
it DC releases comic with pregnant Joker
who births a son
it's real look at this
Joshua Bell says today DC released a
comic in which the Joker becomes
pregnant and gives birth to a mud
monster who transforms into a child's
version of himself who he adopts as his
son I don't know how much longer I can
do this well I don't know though like is
it really that bad that the Joker has a
mud baby that turns into a little Joker
like is it just a mud baby is it
officially a mud baby it literally says
oh it says yeah he gives birth to a mud
monster yeah out of his you know what
out of his butthole I guess it says it's
uh it's on the it's that's what that's
what you guys so so uh I I don't know if
I'm supposed to be mad about this it's
like it's a comic and it's weird and
it's stupid it has people talking about
it I think it's it's it's done for Pure
marketing purposes just to have some
individuals freak out about it just so
they could sell more comic books I think
they understand this more than ever now
and they have us talking about it right
yeah apparently oh what we're gonna say
I don't think anybody's buying this
comic book uh because they did this I
don't think it's good marketing I think
they're doing it because it's satanic
it's absolutely evil that's why they
keep trying to confuse the children I
saw you got the book right over there
genderqueer yeah they put that in
kindergarten libraries it's got pictures
of family financial yeah yeah it's got
pictures of man on man boy on boy child
on child graphic picture pictures and
that's what they want to teach the kids
they're trying to take this generation
and and you know the lgbtq they want to
add a p they want to add a p which
stands for pedophile that's what these
people are trying to put into the
culture yeah that lgbtq so I think a
little too far because lesbians are not
queer or I don't think so unless the
definition has changed they're not trans
so T and L aren't the same thing YT
defines a different thing it defines a
statement of identity not even like of
what attraction you have right like so I
believe so yeah it's t for transsexual
so it's like not an L whereas l g and B
I'll refer to like the way you are to
the rest of the world I want to give you
guys a little context of the Joker got
pregnant or is that well I have it right
here how did he get pregnant did he sit
on something Zatanna is a magic Caster
who curses him trying to sterilize him
because he was trying to hook up with
her but he falls into mud and
accidentally becomes pregnant I guess
yeah she says you can never procreate
with someone else so he does it with
himself I guess
he wakes up and uh there he is like
getting out of bed it's like here's a
joker and they're like oh hey look
you're pregnant
and then here's what is this is this uh
Atomic Skull it's Dr phosphorus atomic
skull never even finished pre-med
this seems like it's supposed to be a
joke and then oh he barfs it doesn't
come out of his butt and then it is okay
look apparently I didn't I didn't know
that but the phrase mud baby is
offensive or something it's meant to be
a slur is that what it is I think that's
a racist term is what they say well he
gives birth to a baby that is made of
mud like so they did that and then the
baby turns into a little Joker I guess
for some reason so it sounds more like
indigestion than uh a birthing process
but if they're going to tell us he was
pregnant that's part of the storyline
who's to say it's why why did the
audience for this I don't know what else
they're trying to create story they're
trying to make and create they have so
much money and they're able to take such
a loss that they just do the weirdest
stuff and hope that people start to get
upset well look look I mean to be honest
a lot of stuff is stagnant culture is
just repetitious it's a new Spider-Man
the same stories over and over and over
again so that's why I'm kind of like I
don't know he he vomits Up Mud that
turns into a baby Joker I don't know if
I'm complaining about that it's not it's
not like some weird it's just a weird
story whatever God help us it did I mean
so it didn't come out of his took us no
he barfs it up he barfs up a baby I get
how you give birth I I bet when they
were writing it they were like we can't
have them crap it out you know yeah
though they should have or burst out of
his stomach it's a little too graphic
yeah and then they try to kill it I
guess that's the plan they're like oh no
no that's a die I don't know man is this
is this get what go broke or uh I don't
know
it's not it's yeah it is it's like a
form of impact investment these
corporations take the your ESG money
with BlackRock and they'll invested in
things that they want to happen on Earth
regardless of if there's going to be a
profit and they think that that the
profit will be that you get to live in a
world that we want you to live that's
good for you uh and that's the same
thing what they're doing they're not
doing this to make money they're doing
this to change culture and take a hit on
their finances it's impact they're doing
it for impact they're trying to lose
money or they're willing to lose money
to change culture I don't know DC uh
lost a lot of money I think they just
stopped Batgirl uh Wonder Woman
Superwoman all of those kind of shows I
think we're we're canceled because they
were absolute crap and people were like
there's no way we're going to be
watching any of this nonsense I think
culturally we are at a very interesting
moment where I think there is a bigger
pushback against this larger agenda
against this larger nonsense which is
absolutely nonsensical which of course
these big multinational corporations
don't actually care about they're just
trying to use it as a way to of course
indoctrinate people and gain some money
uh I think money is an incentive here I
think they don't care but I think uh you
know with the way that DC has been
handling themselves over the past few
months I don't think this was deliberate
I think this was just someone trying to
be maybe edgy trying to get people to
talk about it trying to get some
interest there and doing something
different for uh for finally other than
regurgitating an old story and just
repackaging it with the right labels and
personalities and and uh you know cues
this is why the right needs to make our
own stuff John De La Rose an amazing
writer writes right-wing comic books it
has none of this woke disgusting crap
and this stuff is is getting into the
comics the movies and the video games
that's why we made the fake news turkey
shoot writtenhousegame.com because even
Grand Theft Auto they're trying to turn
that into some kind of feminist game we
need right-winning things
writtenhousegame.com the fake news
turkey shoot if you don't support
right-wing culture you're going to get
more Joker puking out a baby so the game
is fun by the way that we just made the
first level free on writtenhousegame.com
they're making GTA like you get to be a
woman because the big complaint everyone
had was that they wanted to be a woman
as they went around committing crimes
and murdering people and all that stuff
I guess it's like a female protagonist
for the first time I wonder if they're
gonna have male prostitutes in there too
like okay here right here I guess here's
the issue I see with all of this woke
culture stuff is like
why is it that rom-coms are are
considered to be like movies for women
why is it that action Flex our movies
for men is it because they naturally
just tend towards those things guys
don't want to watch rom-coms they want
to see Bruce Willis jump out of a
skyscraper again for like the 18th time
women don't want to watch a guy jump out
of a skyscraper for the 18th time but
sometimes do especially if they're
hanging out with their friends and it's
a fun entertaining flick but like what
they tried to do
they tried doing a a rom-com with only
men that Bros movie where they're all
gay and it bombs and they had in that
movie jokes about gay orgies and I'm
like here's the thing dude
there's not enough people who understand
the context of that humor to understand
why it's funny that there's a gay orgy
happening like what the joke is and then
they put women in masculine roles and
give them male motivations and wonder
why these movies are struggling I
thought Wonder Woman was good because
she was strong you know Wonder Woman
Diana but uh she actually had some like
motherly qualities like the the debate
between her and Chris Pine's character
was like a pragmatist versus a realist
was like a mother versus a father it
worked pretty well but then they try and
just make films where it's a female with
male goals take a look at Hunger Games
it was a Katniss Everdeen female action
hero whose motivation was to protect her
family but she very much was trying to
stay away from the conflict it was it
was it was a very different kind of
narrative she didn't want to be involved
she didn't want the war just leave me
alone leave my family alone and they
force her into the conflict where
typically with a male character it's
like they're thrust into Adventure but
then you end up with these weird we're
going to make a movie we're gonna make
the main main character who's actually
in the in the in the book A man into a
woman and then they wonder why these
things don't work we need right wing
movies too that's why I'm also I'm also
putting out a film anti-white movie
we're talking about all the disgusting
things the media is trying to push
divide Society if we don't make
right-wing films if we don't make things
everybody talks about you know promote
right-wing culture somebody's got to do
it we got to make this stuff
anti-whitemovie.com we have to actually
get things going I know Tim is Tim is
putting out his skateboards I saw the
the logo we have to make right wing
things and people say you know Matt
Brainerd loves to talk about economic
nationalism and that's what we need we
need people that actually build things
and the right has to support it I want
to even just make the best stuff yes the
best art on Earth yeah that little kids
that don't understand politics are drawn
to so you get them before they get
indoctrinated and then you can be like
teaching them about kindness and
Christian you know whatever philosophy
this is the thing the welcome cult
struggles with philosophy the if if you
actually understood if I'll put it this
way I don't think you could take a woke
person have him go up into the mountains
with some like Yogi Monk and meditate
and have them stay woke I think if
people start to understand Concepts
about nature reality God these ideas
around it they they say okay those ideas
don't work maybe some of these people
don't have the capabilities that they
struggle with it but I think with with
the woke cult a lack of philosophical
understanding is what drives a lot of
them being locked into the cult I used
to laugh at I might have brought this up
on the show uh Mr Rogers did you ever
watch that show he's so nice yeah and I
would my parents would tell me you're
you're okay Justice who you are it's
okay to be you even if it feels weird
even if it's you're sad and you're
crying they're mean to you it's okay and
so I saw it as redundant I'd see Mr
Rogers say that same kind of stuff and I
was like oh this is boring but I think
other kids now I'm realizing they didn't
have parents like me some of them didn't
have parents at all and they weren't
told they're okay being who they are and
so now they're looking to find a way to
become okay and we need people like that
I want to talk to you guys about the um
the negative repercussions of getting
woke and how you will then go broke by
showing you this image on the screen
this is a picture of uh just a circle I
don't think I can actually maybe I can
um just make it smaller or something
there you go it's uh it's it's a t for
timcast and it is uh it is the new logo
for Tim cast skateboard company and uh
we're gonna put on all of our stuff and
you can immediately see everybody who
doesn't understand what's going on say
independent trucks Indie trucks people
are saying Tim that's the logo for
independent trucks no it's not no it's
not you are all very wrong this is the
logo for timcast skateboard company it's
a t let me pull up this website
independenttrucks.com do you see a logo
anywhere that looks like that here's
just the word independent written in a
very awful way that's hard to read let's
uh let's scroll down I don't see
anything anywhere with that symbol oh
what's this down here at the bottom you
can't see it but it says our logo let me
click on it about the independent truck
company logo
in a minute truck company chose the
rounded cross logos at its founding in
the late 1970s from day one the
independent logo has represented the
passion for skateboarding the
independent rounded cross design is not
an iron cross which has straight sides
and is not a racist hate symbol
independent truck company does not and
has never stood for the promotion of
hate we strongly denounce all forms of
discrimination racism hate and racial
Injustice we believe in the power of
skateboarding as a positive force in the
world
well I got news for you nowhere on the
website that I've been able to find can
you see that logo they reference you see
the symbol they use now is this up here
in the top left get woke go broke I
hereby officially State wait then you
should probably look for a patent lawyer
to go into trademarks and logos through
the US government before you decide
because they might still own the logo I
hereby officially States the new logo of
Tim cat's skateboard company is this
rounded cross symbol yeah looks cool and
it's not an iron cross you're right
about that that's a t or is it it's an
iron cross the Iron Cross has flat sides
we could even bring them up side by side
I don't know maybe we shouldn't the Iron
Cross wasn't a religious hate symbol
that was the swastika the Iron Cross was
the symbol of the German uh the the
government before Hitler came to power
he basically used it I mean he did use
it but so look you have the Kaiser
independent trucks used to have that
symbol on all of their trucks in fact in
our Escape our garage right now I have a
box full of independent trucks because
those are the trucks that I skateboard
on the trucks are the metal Parts the
hangers where the wheels attached to
attach the board my favorite com my
favorite uh truck company you got it's I
don't like any of the other ones and
it's got that rounded cross symbol on it
a few years ago and I only found this
out recently they started getting
attacked by woke people because they
said that was an iron cross and it was
racist so the company dropped the logo
from all their products
all right yeah so here's what I'm
thinking okay you're right Ian maybe
they would still want to claim ownership
of the iron cross symbol that they use
for their logo all right maybe
Independent Truck Company would like to
have a public court battle about how the
Iron Cross is their company logo and
then we can argue about one why they no
longer use it and why they think it's
theirs despite the fact they don't use
it and then I'll make sure everybody
knows they really really want ownership
of that symbol that they think is racist
and got rid of hey that's a way to go
about it look man
if they don't want to use the symbol and
they've taken it off their products how
can they claim to own it they have
stated that they are they acknowledge
the backlash they acknowledge they were
accused of being racist for using that
symbol they don't want to use it and
they took it off all their products
sure they'll say yeah yeah yeah but it
is still owned by the company I'll make
the argument that I'll call their Bluff
let's see them publicly announce the
iron cross symbol that they got rid of
is theirs because if they took it off
their products they clearly don't want
to be associated with it I accept those
terms I would love to have their 50 year
old iconic brand logo be associated with
my company instead and uh if they don't
want it sure someone in chat put iron
Crossland
they said it goes back to the Crusades
the Iron Cross yeah and just be and it
was used as a Syrian symbol back to 6000
BC I don't know exactly so I'll put it
this way there's two things to be said
they clearly uh they they took it off
their website they took it off all their
products they were saying it's not the
Iron Cross it's not the Iron Cross but
they got rid of it anyway now why would
they get rid of it because they know for
a fact it is the Iron Cross right and
they know that people were calling him
out for using it
they can't own the Iron Cross I would
actually argue one of the reasons they
may have gotten rid of it is that I'd be
willing to bet a lawyer came to them and
said look guys I know you've been using
this for 50 years but everybody is
asserting that is the iron cross a judge
will not agree with you that's an
original logo he's going to say that's a
nine across and you can argue you
rounded the edges but imagine someone
coming out and taking a swastika and
rounding the edges an arguing it's not a
swastika nice try dude not going to work
I think they may have changed it because
they realize they can't actually own
that symbol as it is and this was
like let's let's be honest the Catalyst
for this was them being called racist
and having to get rid of it but let's
play baby you want to get go broke I'm
gonna I'll I'll Tim kest skateboard
company will launch a bunch of boards
and wheels with that logo and we'll
start selling it this is what America
needs this is the way forward because if
we keep giving money to woke companies
like the skateboard company Tim's about
to take independent then those companies
turn around they they donate to
Democrats they donate to rhinos like
Mitt Romney like um this this jerky this
is just the first product from Big Club
USA bigclubusa.com but we're going to be
going after things like toilet paper if
you go into a Target buy any of the
toilet papers those companies give to
Democrats give to people like Mitt
Romney Target themselves all of these
companies hate you they are donating to
people that want to destroy you and so
the only way forward you have to create
economies within ourselves you can't
keep giving your money to your oppressor
and say why aren't we winning you you
have to empower people in your own
Community to lift us up that's Tim's
skateboards that's bigclubusa.com I just
want to point out how on their website
at the bottom of the website on every
page you can see it says our logo
and then it brings you to this this
apology of like no no it's not an iron
cross we're not racist please please I
think by saying that and then later
taking the logo off all their products
they asserted it was bad and they didn't
want to use it and they didn't want to
be associated with it did they just I
don't think they have a right to claim
that that's that symbol belongs to them
and so it's it's ourselves they just
take it off like within the last week or
so no it's been years when I search
Independent Truck Co it comes up on the
search result on the right the iron
three years ago the company dropped the
logo from their products but like right
here on the search it shows it that's
that that's unrelated to the company
okay it used to be their logo and they
decided they didn't want to use it
anymore so I would like to see this
company argue in court that they do want
to be associated with the Iron Cross
please Independent Truck Company stand
up loud and proud and say that the Iron
Cross is your logo and that no one else
should be allowed to use it I would love
for you to publicly announce that and
and then we'll make sure we get enough
press about it so that everybody knows
that's your logo look man this is a
couple different things I grew up
skateboarding that is the independent
logo I should say it was the independent
logo and I am offended that this company
cowered in fear because people accuse
him of being racist for using that logo
whether it's the Iron Cross or otherwise
when I was younger we had conversations
is that the Iron Cross are they Nazis
and then you know we learned exactly
what Ian said Assyrians going back
thousands of years it has nothing to do
with it it is not a swastika yeah even
the swastika goes back thousands of
years to Hindu culture it's The Wheel of
Time but Hitler co-opted that like
a rainbow oh yeah exactly he inverted it
and rotated it so there is some argument
my point here is
this company has bent the knee to the
woke cult and said it is no longer a
symbol used by their company so be it we
will keep the imagery and the the
iconography of skateboarding alive
and we will do it with a smile on our
faces because they don't want to I would
think but hey I'll take it I'll take the
alternative and the alternative is
independent reversing their decision
publicly declaring that is their symbol
and I'll make sure everyone hears
themselves but I think even if they do
for some reason still own like a year or
two left on the thing via trademark law
that publicly stating that it's not
their symbol it would be like legal
precedent to use exactly yeah so they
would either need to publicly state it
is their symbol and make sure everybody
knows that is their symbol they're gonna
have to say it but here here's what I'm
saying I think it is honest and fair to
State based on how they've removed it
from all of their products it is no
longer their symbol yeah now if they
want to argue otherwise I'm willing to
hear them out
if they don't want to use that symbol I
have no problem using it and I think it
would be very very good for my brand to
adopt something they've abandoned
yeah why not
yeah we'll go Brooke you want to play
games we'll play games yeah you're like
forcing their hand it's the uh what do
they call it the Fafa chart
yeah
sorry that you know F around find out
yeah there's the meter of like how far
you go and then the ramifications yeah
so I was talking to some skateboarders
earlier who were explaining to me how
the industry's become ridiculously woke
in in crazy ways and they brought this
to my attention and I said wait wait
Indy dropped their logo and it's like
yeah they don't use it anymore it's off
all their products they took it off the
trucks themselves and I was like so I
can use it now yeah and everybody
started laughing and I'm like you think
I'm joking bro if you told me when I was
14 that I'd have a company that had that
logo I'd have told you you were crazy
it's impossible yeah if McDonald's
stopped using the golden arches I'd snag
it up 100 what are you gonna use it for
whatever man who cares man put it on my
wall yo if you don't want to use
something because you don't want to be
called racist bro there's people who are
willing to take that opportunity to your
point though it's incredible what you
can dream and make real in this life
like don't let your memes be dreams kid
get your memory if you really want
something in this world you can make it
happen and Tim's showing you that
believe me I'm seeing that in my life
but people you have more power than you
think and most people don't realize that
did you always think that like before
you got tased I'm gonna I want to talk
about that leading up to that and then
what happened after was there a current
that went into your brain with the taser
and then changed everything like the
time stopped as you're getting tased and
like you can just see the universe and
all the secrets and you're like whoa how
many volts was it it's for everybody on
social media when they get mad at me
they say that like you were tased and
messed with your brain this crazy lady
on this uh social media app called
clubhouse that was calling uh somebody a
[ __ ] slave this crazy lady she was
coming at me with this stuff like people
think it's an insult other people call
me an American hero for the don't tase
me is don't tase me bro incident so
you're not like making me feel bad the
truth of the matter is that whole thing
helped Propel me forward in life in many
many ways like I was given a at that
point I would say I was just starting to
believe in God and the night after I was
arrested I was praying very hard in jail
I wanted everybody to see that story
because it was such a crazy Injustice
I'm asking questions about whether our
elections are valid and I get thrown in
jail for it you specifically were asking
John Kerry about the secret society that
he was with his political opponents
George W bush with in the Skull and
Bones secret society that's that was the
the question that you're asking him
which is a valid important question
there were also eighth cousins they were
related and that that was a sham of an
election between the choices that we
were given uh back then sorry go ahead
no that was an important question that
you asked yeah it was it's funny that I
think the reason the whole thing went so
viral is because nobody was asking
politicians real questions we didn't
have Luke radkowski that was uh really
doing that in a big Way on YouTube yet I
don't think people knew of him yet Alex
Jones as big as he is now was a fraction
of the size Laura Loomer didn't exist
Alex Stein didn't exist so this is the
first time the American public at large
was seeing real questions asked that's
why it went viral on YouTube YouTube
turned off the view counter on the video
that was taken from my camera and
they've they've since Shadow banned it
from search they didn't want people to
see my questions they wanted people only
to see the tasing to see like the
punishment they didn't want people to
learn what's going on and anyway after
all of that happened
yeah it was like a a great uh push
forward for me in my uh Journey as a man
absolutely absolutely I started thinking
around that time is uh the Power of
Words casting spells you know you spell
your words their spells and uh the magic
word magic and when you say double
negatives like don't be evil people are
hearing be evil evil evil evil be evil
and so you say don't tase me bro they're
like tase you bro okay I do believe that
so I try and say the the counter that is
the positive word instead of the
negative negative yes if I had known
more word magic at that time I would
have said the different phrase than
don't talk to me bro people do react to
double to negative energy as well and
it's not always a bad thing it's just
negative which it moves faster like
runaway breakdown out of clouds that's
how lightning forms it's very
lightweight negative energy
um so it there is value to negative
energy as well it's just very dangerous
because it can coagulate and get very
strong and move really fast 2023 is
going to be a really really good year
let's go I think you know there's talk
about recession and stuff maybe but
someone commented earlier today and said
no way it's actually going to be really
really good for the US dollar because
all the bad stuff is hitting foreign
countries who rely on the US Reserve
currency and they're gonna be forced to
buy dollars strengthening our buying
power and I'm like that sounds really
awful like an awful thing to celebrate I
guess like the suffering of others
results in us doing well but seeing the
Kevin McCarthy stuff I I've had some
conversations with musicians with
creatives with pro athletes and there
seems to be we're reaching a breaking
point where people are like I'm just
sick of not being able to just talk
anymore I'm sick of the wokeness and I'm
done with it and we're seeing the
wokeness fail to actually push back in a
lot of ways I I wanna I wanna save some
of the big announcements that may be
coming out in the future but I'm hearing
a lot of really really really good stuff
about breaking the woke narrative and
breaking the mold and bringing us back
to sanity so I'm excited I was watching
I'm like I'm just just sorry I'm like
I'm going through the comments on my
post about the Indie logo and I'm seeing
the response from people and there's and
I'm getting messages from some Pro
skaters and I'm just like this is good
we're gonna win you can take over bro
the whole
Lane is available
that want to do things
industry it's all woke people are sick
of it we can make things and take over
and put away let the Boomers go to sleep
it's you had your time Boomers but the
the based Millennials we're actually
going to build the new Industries I last
night I was watching a video from Dr
Robert Malone talking about the vaccines
and covid and all these things and I was
thinking like and I've been watching the
a lot of these doctors now that are
allowed to speak the the covet narrative
has been lifted you know now we're
realizing like okay it's transmissible
you survive it usually
um and people are talking about it
they're pretty open about it I'm like
how are these people still alive I'm
thinking all these doctors and me and us
and like how are we still alive when
we've been doing this this is because
we're supposed to be because this is
they're not there to like stop us
they're just trying they're trying to do
their thing we're trying to do ours and
we're better like people speak up you
can't stop people from speaking up you
never have been able to do that
amen I could go on probably a two-hour
video monologue about that I mean two
hours yeah I could go that is long I got
two hours go ahead yeah yeah let's go I
was just I'm just reading the comments
and uh I posted on Twitter and Instagram
the logo
a lot of people immediately understood
like they realized the point this
company wanted to get woke
this company was bending the need to
woke people and so they've given up what
is worth probably hundreds of millions
of dollars in brand value that you you
just can't buy it's
1978 and they said you know what we're
going to disassociate ourselves from who
we are when I when I was told this
happened and I'm like I've not been
following a whole lot of skate scene
stuff company-wise I watch a lot of
skaters and and I watch Barrack stuff so
when I looked it up and I saw what their
new logo is I was like is that what
they're doing that's terrible yeah wow
you can't read it and it still throws
back to the Cross days so maybe they
should just flatten it out and have just
the word independent because that's
illness I can't read it they've
destroyed their company yeah they've
they've decided to just throw in the
towel and it's so sad to see that
they've given me this logo but they
really don't want to use it anymore and
I'm I'm I will take it from them and you
know what all of the Heat and all of the
anti all of the all the hate and all the
woke people and antifa who are going to
be yelling at me
I'm willing to accept that negative
consequence that they're clearly not
the best marketing squad on the planet
the crazy leftists yeah you know when
they hate something our side loves it
Ian says that if McDonald's stopped
using the golden arches he'd snag it up
oh that's capitalism it'd be nuts not to
take it you know what I mean seriously
it's crazy you didn't see trucks without
the logo on in the first place like when
I grew up was the same thing it was
everywhere and I I looked up uh I was
like I went to the store and I looked
gone it's just straight metal and I'm
like dude they really said they don't
want it anymore I'm like I will
begrudgingly take
and uh all those stickers at every skate
park and every video that has that
symbol that's Tim Cascade ports now let
me tell you something let me tell you
something if you could go to someone as
a marketing guy all the advertising
people listen
if you could go to a company and they're
like we want to hire you for an ad for a
big ad campaign and the guy said what if
I was able to get your ads back in time
they'd be like what how can you get an
ad for my company back in time watch
this and then you put on a skate video
and everyone's wearing that symbol on
their helmets on their boards yeah and
that's the symbol for Tim Cascade boards
I know thank you thank you very much
thank you so uh timcast skateboards is
the company that is uh going to start
selling those uh
skateboards with that symbol are you
gonna put the words inside of the Cross
like the other no no no no it's just
going to be that symbol that I tweeted
as I said that's the logo and then we're
gonna write Tim Cascade boards
underneath yo can I get a logo copy just
straight logo you can use it yes you can
use it for whatever you want I give you
permission
I love it all right let's go to Super
Chat third eye dude Super Chat I'm gonna
start a competing company called
dependent and do the opposite of that
and make it totally woke do it make it a
giant D you like just a d logo you know
what I mean that's perfect all right
let's get some uh here we go Porkins
Holt says Tim is correct you just use
your trademark to maintain its active
status and gain USPTO protection
I've hereby announced
to the world on this large program that
symbol is associated with my company and
with timcast skateboard company so you
know nobody better use it
except you know I'll give you permission
if you ask oh that's nice yeah and you
can use it okay thanks okay cool all
right let's go super chats if you have
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to the
channel share the show with your friends
become a member at timcast.com we're
gonna have a members only show coming up
here about 11 p.m it's gonna be fun
spicy and not so fast faster faster
faster faster faster that was quick I
could probably go faster if I if if I
actually uh wrote something out and
memorized it I could probably go faster
than that you just that that was just
you double it over and over and over and
over and over yeah if you keep doubling
the speed you sound like Ben Shapiro
eventually buy my goals he can't talk as
fast as I can but people were saying uh
they watch me on one people would be
like I like watching podcasts on one and
a half times speed except for Tim pool
and Ben Shapiro
I think it's a compliment we get we get
through the subjects as quick as we can
we say a lot forever running says Tim
open a coffee location in Nashville
strike a Morning Show deal with Crowder
these are my requests
that'd be a good coffee ad actually
speaking really quick coffee ad yeah you
being able to speak like after he sips
the coffee again
like like beef somebody who can tell if
I've had coffee before a show tweaking
like I've not had a coffee before a show
but
we got these espresso machines and
they're great it's so good you know what
I do I do it for after dinner because it
helps with digestion digestion I'll take
a single shot of delicious and right now
we have uh in our machine coffee brand
coffee because uh Jeremy's quartering oh
yeah shout out it's so good he sent us a
bunch and it's like it pains me to say
it because like we're gonna be launching
our own coffee but Jeremy's coffee is
legit and uh I'm using it I'm using the
right now the light roast for the
espresso single shot I put a little bit
of cocoa in it and a bit of heavy cream
and stir it up it's just sugarless dark
cacao powder yeah just oh man a little
chocolate you actually shoot it where do
you sip on it I sip on it I I enjoy it
IV intravenously he gets it injected no
no Luke puts in his butt
that girl
not a lie
also too much too much caffeine
um also depletes your magnesium so make
sure you're getting enough magnesium
lots of people are not getting enough
magnesium surprises and you get
magnesium vegetables in the chlorophyll
it is the anchor of the chlorophy
stay away from it I was feeling a little
sick you know we had we got covid then
we got better and afterwards I I put in
a call to my doctor Joe Rogan to ask him
about what I should do for my health and
he told me to take vitamins and I just I
think it's funny to calm that because
it's like this is a true story
uh when we got sick I talked to a doctor
and they were just like stay home stay
under in bed I started getting really
sick I hit up Joe and asked him I heard
you did something what did you do he
told me to call the private doctor and I
was like let me call and see what I can
find they gave me a different
prescription a week later I hit up Joe
to thank him I was like bro seriously
thank you so much for like you know just
the conversation and telling me about
what you're doing how you're doing it
and all that stuff and then he was like
are you taking vitamins and I was like
no and he goes bro take vitamins I'm not
joking seriously start now and so I've
been taking vitamins ever since yeah I I
should when I I'm on TV and saying what
you should do I'm not a doctor and if
green vegetables might not be right for
you I don't know if that's the right
place for you to derive your magnesium
from it's the way I do it I've recently
been taking magnesium my mom gave me
these little calm uh little chewy things
stay away from that I I would get it
from a different Source but magnesium
magnesium is is legit a lot of people
need more magnesium but uh be careful
too much makes you poop uh exactly
that's why I think I'm gonna be doing uh
Luke but chugging coffee brown coffee
use that logo for Butt Coffee which one
the the the the the the the the cross
thing which cross thing the cross logo
we just independent
no no no no I'm gonna do the dependent
butt chugging
yep uh so that's gonna come that's gonna
be coming soon so stay actually pay
attention that's a better idea
dependent dude because like they're
gonna have the choice between being
called racist and having that logo
associated with putting coffee up your
ass
and it's like the crosshairs and then
the commercials no the causes the
crosses of puckered anus yeah all right
and then and then coffee is going to be
spilling out of it
and then there's gonna be like oh
somebody's rotating go broke something's
going to be rotating and the coffee's
gonna be like you know dude the
Magnesium molecule looks like the uh THC
molecule yeah what magnesium would you
recommend to use do you have a
particular one you take there's a lot of
different forms of magnesium do your own
research but a lot of people are
deficient in it uh but a lot of the
mainline Brands usually just have a lot
of other stuff mixed into it and
impurities and really bad stuff that are
not good for you ask your doctor about
blood work so they can tell you about
what you may or may not be missing and
they can give you good advice but it's
one thing to be like maybe you're
missing magnesium but maybe you're not
you go you get your blood work done they
can tell you if you've got stress they
can tell you about your cholesterol they
can tell you about vitamins do that at
least once a year that's what I
recommend to people do to do on my
members area I'm like get blood work
once a year see where your levels are at
and then kind of try to naturally fix it
you can't naturally fix it supplement
and then try to fix any problems all
right we got we gotta read more Super
chats here we got uh metallic blade says
the Republicans are delaying the vote
until January 6th and then they will all
vote for Trump the j6 secret Trump
Insurrection
Clem Everly says I'm a retired military
police I cannot tell you how many times
in training myself and countless others
did in fact say don't tase me bro what's
good it was epic it's it's it's still a
meme the way you were saying it too they
put it in minions the new Minions movie
can we play yeah yeah he uses a cheese
gun and the guy behind the counter says
don't cheese me bro I appreciate it
people are mad they did that too like
don't you know he's a racist how dare
you
did we pull that video up is that like
easily snaggable probably maybe but
maybe we'll get for the members
a lot of people we got uh nibup sang
adjourned until January 6th in
Insurrection two Trump the speaker
Boogaloo yo if that actually happened
and Kevin McCarthy was in on it I owe
that meant an apology I would I would
buy him a pizza and a cake and be like
thank you sir but come on he's not doing
that uh no McCarthy comes out and says
the whole reason we delayed the vote was
that we could all nominate Trump and
they'll start clapping and cheering I'd
be like I was wrong yeah I'm still
waiting for all the Q Anon sealed
indictments where are the hundreds of
arrests that we were promised are The
Satellites with all the information on
them right from Germany right there were
some satellites I think yeah server
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Fox News host
called the no Kevin's insurrectionists
these people are crazy who said that who
on Fox news said that
John beer says Roberto Jr 2024 Raymond
Stanley Jr 2032 Ian is Vice President we
are going to make a Roberto Roberto Jr
pro model skateboard yeah coming soon
man coming soon Roberto Jr promo uh
someone just wrote a Super Chat uh
related to the conversation we had if
you don't mind if I could just read it
yeah this one is from nurse shark he
says trust Luke to attempt to make a
logo depicting diarrhea look cool
depend didn't should be the company get
it depends depends depends dependent
should be the name of the company but
then but then your ragged on depends man
and they're they're an honorable brand
for people who are in need of course but
you know sometimes people got to have
coffee
anus
what do we got let's grab some more King
pancake says question for Ian do you
still play Banner Lord if so who's your
favorite faction and do you play with
mods if not I've got quite a few I could
recommend it really enriches the
campaign and gameplay lovely mod what
was last thing landia for Life landia I
used to be valandian when I had to play
the first Mountain blade but I play as
the couzets now I love horse archery so
I'll get a big glaive or like so I I try
not to use Shields are nice you know
Shields are nice but sometimes that that
big old glaive man just one shots dudes
over it over and over but I play on the
hardest difficulty so if I take an arrow
I'm pretty much to the knee yeah or the
head or whatever that could be the end
of the game so I Gotta Be You Gotta
Shields are nice but I do love the
two-handed weapons uh yeah and no I
don't play it anymore I haven't played
it in like four a month and a half as a
federal pixelated Apollo is the guy to
watch on YouTube for Mountain blade he
says I need something better than Fox
Biz when at work morning live show with
Hannah Claire and Phil will be fire do
work son never cover speaker Trump yeah
so I guess it's like a new year after
2020 I think it was 2021 I stopped I cut
half of my segments down that I did on
the morning show and now we're getting
to 2023 and I kind of feel like we got
to change because this the model that I
have for the morning show is just read
the news record a half an hour segment
read the news record a half an hour
segment and I'm like we could do more
the idea would be that process where I'm
just hanging out and reading the news we
just do a live stream and ideally once
we get the new studio up it'll look way
way cooler and then Phil Labonte says he
wants he's down to be involved so he's
going to come out we're going to talk
about this and then Hannah Claire would
hang out and so what it would be is 9 to
2 p.m live every day
I'm there from nine to like noon and
then while we're live I'll actually hit
the record button and do my segment like
normal upload it around noon I get up
peace out maybe someone else Pops in
we're talking to ilad aliyahu he can
come in and hang out
and then we just have people from The
Newsroom coming and talking and hanging
out until like two or maybe maybe
depending we have someone come into an
hour uh because then we have pop culture
crisis at three so what this will do is
be infinitely more fun generate new
content utilizing new space allow me to
have assistance in the work that I do
and get done quicker and I I just think
it'll it'll just be fun that's all
that's all I'm thinking about I'm like
what are we doing it's been you know
it's been uh we're going on I did 2021
and 2022 with the same model I'm getting
bored let's let's spice it up let's do
something in the morning and the
technology changes so your tactics
change like I used to be obsessed with
video responses on YouTube but I think
it's a defunct Tech now like you can you
make Twitter video responses in Twitter
threads with at tags it's way easier to
follow I think than the old I wouldn't
know since I'm banned on Twitter Elon
Musk restore at the Andrew Meyer trucker
and Torah says this is for Ian first
half an hour Ian with the consecutive
20s keep it up thanks dog that's right
trapping drop in those 20s holla
Trace Ventura says bobert filmed the
Knowles interview in Tim's garage LMAO
the background did look like my garage
yeah it was kind of weird same thing
like her uh her videos not here though
her like AV was really good so nice job
Lauren a lot of sometimes politicians
just don't get it they have a cheap
webcam like yeah step it up whoa you can
do audio could have been better yeah
that's right kalishnikov says
pre-campaign Trump was better because it
was just a man and his Twitter now it's
a man surrounded by an army of
consultants and advisors and his truth
social I think this explains his latest
spree of PR blunders
I yeah I also want to mention that I put
up a poll as kind of a joke it says did
you smash the like button it's at 61 yes
and 39 no but we actually have way more
likes than we've we typically get so I
guess the poll Works to get people to
hit the like button yeah I clicked yes
and then immediately clicked the like
button so I lied but I then made it
right I do appreciate it I was just
thinking because we did the poll on uh
is it funny that McCarthy lost 11 times
everyone said yes and then I was like we
normally put up a thing saying smash the
like button so I did a poll I think
we'll just we'll do we'll do various
silly polls in that way uh every day
just for fun
Rhys Mendocino red trickle for the win
enough to eat the Democrats but not
enough to give the Kami Republicans all
the power heart
here here
ah this is a brutal one pro gun says dan
Crenshaw is just John McCain without the
depth of perception oh that's mean dude
but he is McCain you know I'll I accept
that one yeah Cassandra Fairbank says
the greatest McCain tweets of all time
he's talking about him burning in hell
and I love her for that who was it I
think it was Trump he said like after
McCain died something about looking up
remember that he was like I hope maybe
he's looking down not on all of us and
waving or up or something like that and
then everyone I was laughing my ass off
looking up it was that's a brutal thing
like even with Hitler's death I I'm like
I'm glad the threat is gone but it's
horrible that that happened to him he
became that it sucks that death has to
happen when I I think so I think I have
to talk about my religious views are
much about creating systems creating
life creating ideas and not destroying
them so the idea that destruction is
necessary for the preservation of
creation is a sad thing it's very real
though that's what eating is yeah yep
you know breaking things down and
absorbing it you know what the Messiah
is supposed to bring though it's a
supposed to bring the end of death the
end of pain suffering and death so what
you wish for that's what we're supposed
to get to stem cells that's why we have
this life regeneration therapy that
technology they're talking about
immortality Tech right now Roth Berg has
a great book immortality by Rob Berg and
like there's going to be a scientist
who's working on the Breakthrough and
his name is going to be like Jesus
Martinez or something
he's going to be he's going to be like
you know I I think we've cracked stem
cell regenerative therapy to reverse
aging everyone's going to look at each
other and be like
it'll come out of Harvard David I think
that technology will come one now Jesus
Sinclair Jesus the question is are the
people like Hillary Clinton's of the
world going to control it or will it be
for everyone I wouldn't be surprised if
they already have it and they already
control it
all right Leland Taylor says fetterman
for unable to Speaker of the House
[Laughter]
he's uh he's recovering I haven't seen
him I haven't seen him lately you guys
see anything Dave says just in a match
for a speaker an actual Unity option who
wants to fix and open the process I
don't think so why not because because
the idea with within a mash speakership
is that he compromises with the
Democrats and then nothing actually
happens
it's like dude the Democrats ran rough
shot over over Trump the Maga candidates
and everything with subpoenas and j6
committee Republicans need to
investigate malfeasance and get
accountability you bring in one of these
unit candidates and they're gonna say
now now everybody lay down your swords
and we're gonna get through this
together nah we want we want subpoenas
we we need investigations that's right
Carlo Magno TV says Andrew Trump is
playing 40 chess he nominated McCarthy
because he knows he will be shut down
yeah Charles been playing 40 chess for a
long time you know he put in Bolton 4D
chess he put in mcmaster's 40 chest he
fired Flynn 40 chess David Dave Rubin
had a good one he was like what 40 chest
by mail how long is it going to take
when does he win yeah the real 4D chest
would have been if he listened to his
best advisors people like Ali Alexander
Roger Stone he did something to combat
all of the uh potential election fraud
and yeah he hasn't been listening to his
smartest people he's been listening to
people that are just making a buck and
that's sad
Chelsea versus Matt G or Lauren B should
nominate themselves or each other
or whatever at this point they were like
voting for Hearn like it's just like
just kind of voting all over the place
they're just saying they're just
basically saying no to McCarthy he can't
win yeah I I dig it he deserves it this
is fantastic by the way all right
Jesse Padilla says one of the house reps
to just find a random homeless person
and nominate the random homeless person
for Speaker of the House someone should
nominate a homeless person named Kevin
McCarthy oh man that way when everyone's
like McCarthy they're like which one I
guess the homeless guy would it be funny
if like Matt Gates walks in and he like
he's he's carrying an ID that says Kevin
McCarthy he gets his name changed and
then when Kevin McCarthy wins he walks
up and says which one like I am also
Kevin McCarthy it's like then he wins
and he's the speaker that's the way the
rules work I'm sure of it it's like V
for Vendetta that's right it comes out
with those masks on
maxer says administrative State puts no
effort into its own operation remember
how Jesse faden was able to just walk
into the Federal Bureau of control and
they immediately made her the director
it needs to change no I didn't know
about that what is that first I've heard
of it yeah
peas and butter says Michael malice for
speaker
I would I would yes that would be
fantastic I support that he's got more
Integrity than uh
well I was gonna say anybody but that
Byron Donald's he seems like a stand-up
guy so also more Integrity than just
about anybody that would be nominated
now
Quantum strange Quark says Shaka when
the walls fell 11 times
I dig it you guys know the reference
Shaka Zulu no it's uh Star Trek the Next
Generation there was a race of aliens
that only spoke in like idiomatic
metaphor or whatever and so they would
say things like Shaka when the walls
fell referring to a story that conveyed
an idea
and so like they were confused because
they were like you're just saying it's
like what does this mean and then they
had to learn to speak the language
because the translators couldn't
translate a different form of metaphoric
communication that was a good episode
yeah I just thought the walls fell
that's right
all right let's see
grab another Super Chat Conor McLaren
says question for Andrew understanding
Torah in the word of God do you
understand or believe in the bearish
sheet prophecy
I don't know what he's referring to you
got to be more specific brother you know
there you go
ligamouth again says yay is an
uneducated madman he was given many
chances to defend his positions from
scrutiny and he ran this ridiculous
meltdown was pure poison to the
opposition to the far left there will be
no chance to beat the far left unless we
move past him now
you know yay has his own kind of
education just because he wasn't
educated the way you don't like it you
know or was educated or whatever you
don't understand doesn't mean he's not
educated and calling someone mad that
you don't understand also it's like if
you don't have two people are talking in
Spanish and you don't speak Spanish
You're Gonna think they're crazy because
they're making no sense to you but in
fact you're the uneducated one
something that bothered me with the
whole yay situation when he went on Lex
Friedman's show Lex Friedman told him if
you name people specifically I'll help
you and then yay dropped the text
message of Harley Pasternak threatening
to get yay institutionalized and that
he'll never be able to play with his
kids normally again and Lex Freeman
didn't say anything about that and
people are just acting like that didn't
happen like this guy who's got some kind
of ties to like the Canadian version of
MK Ultra is connected to all these weird
deaths and things in Hollywood and he's
making these threats to yay in his text
messages and nobody's talking about that
I just I just find that uh oh gay is
crazy why because he was
institutionalized by this MK Ultra dude
from Canada it's a very strange
situation that not enough people are
talking about we actually came up on the
show when yay was on the show I was
hoping to have a full conversation with
him about that and it's as if the
spiritual battle that is going on
prevented it from coming out that night
but hold on think about the interview
that we had with yay versus what
happened with Alex Jones and look no
disrespect to Alex to Alex Jones but
when yay said something about Hitler not
going after Jewish people Alex just went
I think he did Target some people like
come on dude that's pretty floppy what I
what I feel like is we were not letting
yay just say these things when when Luke
tried bringing up Pasternak to bring it
to specific individuals yay shifted the
subject back to everybody and we were
like nah dude we're not doing this so he
gets up and leaves he goes to Alex Jones
Alex Jones gives him more leeway he goes
off the rails and says even more crazier
things yeah I specifically brought up
the military unit that Pastor Nick was a
part of I brought up a lot of other
correlative information especially what
Dave Chappelle was saying in the
industry that goes along with what he
was saying there were some bigger truths
we were hoping to uncover here but he
didn't want to have that conversation
yeah I'd love to see a do-over I'd love
to see round two yeah that'd be fun
track media only says no DC is still
very woke the shake-up is only in the
wbdc movies right now
well maybe it'll change I'm I'm feeling
pretty good about this year Marvel is
realizing that they they had a string of
bad quality movies because they were
trying to play some stupid games maybe
they'll get back and you know fix things
like
Doctor Strange is one of my favorite
movies
Doctor Strange too was me because they
tried doing this thing where it's like
they have America whatever the
character's name is her name is America
or something and she can punch holes
through the Multiverse I get what
they're trying to do they want to do
Secret Wars but too much of modern uh
Marvel is what they're they're trying to
bring in diverse characters because they
want to expand their market share
I can respect it like they they want to
make a character who is you know they
did uh Kamala Khan she's you know Muslim
or whatever because they're like we want
to create something that's going to
relate but they also go overboard with
it so they make a Muslim female
character and they give a female
character male motivations and then they
wonder why there's a backlash to it it's
like dude you wanna make a Muslim
character make a Muslim character but
give them like just write a good story
that's not what they're doing they're
just taking like okay we're gonna be
woke so we're gonna do you know this
minority this disability neurodivergence
this religion and then there you go
there's your character and it's like
that doesn't make a character have
personality or anything like that like
that Meme of somebody throwing uh adult
toys at a dartboard to write a Vice news
story but I'm happy that they're failing
so badly because it opens up a lane uh
Stars entwined written by John delaros
that could be the right Wings Star Wars
I would love to make those films one day
and if Marvel keeps failing that this
badly we're going to get to the point
where we replace that whole industry so
keep going Marvel make your next hero uh
disabled [ __ ] whatever yeah you know
spawn was a black dude I don't know if
anyone knows that I mean that was one of
my favorite superheroes of all time Todd
McFarland but it didn't matter what
color his skin was because he's spawned
this is a good one Thomas sidebottom
says honestly if they had done the Joker
baby thing five years ago I would have
been cool with it but my tolerance for
woke content has dropped so much that I
just can't handle things like this
anymore you know what I kind of feel
that way too that's what I was thinking
about it it's just like I don't know
what their intention was with it it's
not the wokest thing ever but I just
don't care I'm just get it away dude
have the Joker what did he do the Joker
shot Barbara Gordon like get back to
those what I liked about a lot of those
comics in in this era the eight late 80s
and stuff was that they went for Comics
went from being silly hokey you know
Batman in the 60s or whatever to really
dark stories or it's like the Joker
legit paralyzes a woman crazy stuff is
that like
um more he was kind of attributed I
think so Alan Moore yeah and then like
Jim Lee brought a lot of really
interesting Frank Miller Miller yep yeah
and uh Watchmen was also very good so
it's like taking these ideas of
superheroes but then applying like a
kind of a dark reality to It joker shot
Barbara Gordon through the stomach
pierces her spine and she gets paralyzed
becomes Oracle like that's a brutal
story dude now it's just like the joke
is pregnant and barfing Up Mud yeah okay
I guess took the claws off of it yeah
where are we at Brody Nevis says Hey
guys love the show Ian I would love to
be a part of the DND show as a player
haven't done any acting VC work but I'm
willing to do that to be part of the
show I think there was a
miscommunication we're not looking for
players um we're looking for a DM that
can also play every once in a while if I
want a DM because I like dming too it's
just a lot of work to come up I was
actually thinking last night I might DM
like I think we got six people to play
and or five and then a rotating the
problem is everybody here's got a job
and it's good time consuming three four
or five hours on the weekend every
weekend is that something we want to do
I mean we might need players
professional DND
professional player but it's really more
like a professional imaginative Party
friend how did the uh critical role find
each other were they all friends before
they started the DND thing I wouldn't be
surprised if they did a casting of
charismatic people who understood table
games and then said well don't worry we
can teach you how to play D D have fun
and then they bring in guests
periodically or something casting that
would be like DC where you need like a
casting agent we need a place people to
come in read on camera send video but
like I don't know not there yet not
there yet you can always send me a link
to your resume meaning video of your
work of you communicating with players
your I want to see your campaign setting
I want to see how you interact with the
speed the Cadence I need to see all that
before I know if that'll work with you
essay federally says also on independent
trucks you are legally required to
protect your patents and trademarks or
you lose them I I am saying outright
I think when they took those logos off
they officially said this is not us
anymore yeah I am using that logo it is
Tim Cass skateboards they and dependent
butt chug coffee damn right up your
coffee oh no that's
coffee there's going to be a lot of puns
we can make with this but uh I'm running
with this I'm already reaching out to a
company that does uh coffee for you know
what well Alex Rodriguez says Tim as a
Spanish speaker when you said the name
zatana it sounds too similar to the
Spanish name for Satan satanus The Joker
got busy with the devil excuse me no uh
zatana is like
a stage magician her character is like
she wears the traditional Spandex and
like top hat and she has a wand and um I
don't know too much about her character
she looks like a magician's assistant
but she can actually do magic yeah
exactly exactly she cursed The Joker I
guess okay she impregnated him so a lady
impregnated The Joker with magic
and then he barfed Up Mud that was also
a baby
and then it turned into him I mean just
brilliant stuff Jesus genius really
you know I but I my thing is like I do
like wacky weird stuff sometimes but I'm
just I I was a good point like my
tolerance for weakness also is very low
when they do it every single time you
know there's an agenda and it's just
it's enough it's so you just know that
they're not focusing on the story
they're focusing on a narrative that
they want you desperately to believe in
and and that's when I know like this
show is going to be crap they don't give
a damn about them they don't give a damn
about entertaining you they give a damn
about indoctrinating you that's a big
difference
porks and Holt says Tim is correct you
just use your trademark to maintain its
active status and gain USP PTO
protection and they're not using it I
officially am I I officially announced
I'm using it earlier today you
officially announced it that's right now
if anybody uses it I've already said it
you're infringing on my my trademark
that's that's that's the Tim you did not
want to get into a trademark
yeah it's a good one it's a good one
yeah we're gonna we're I'm gonna I'm
gonna sell stickers and Tim Cascade
boards will sell sick boards you know
maybe we'll make a drink and we'll put
that on the can be cool yeah yeah think
think about it this way
that symbol is on stickers is in movies
is on skate ramps it's in photographs
for 50 years and they abandoned it yeah
and now I get to have advertisements go
back in time that's that's magic right
there and then there's going to be some
little kid and be like Grandpa what's
that symbol on the skateboard in your
picture and he's gonna go oh I can't
remember let me look it up what was that
one oh Tim cast skateboards that's what
it was and I'll do that that's right you
can put it on it's a good uh
three-dimensional logo too it can fit on
like circular round surfaces that's
right spherical
JJ says your cross is the same shape as
the Russian order of Courage that is my
cross thank you very much for for
noticing that
Connor McLaren says the bear sheet
prophecy is the beginning in English the
first word of the Torah is the whole
story of the 7 000 year coming of the
Messiah hidden in Hebrew
okay all right ladies and gentlemen if
you haven't already I guess you did
Smash the like button I guess putting up
the poll asking if you smash the like
button worked because we have 18 000
likes right now so thank you so much for
smashing the like button subscribe to
this channel share the share with your
friends become a member at timcast.com
we're going to have that members only
show coming up for you in about 45
minutes to an hour you don't want to
miss it it's not family friendly it is
good fun and we could use your support
as members at timcast so we can do
things like launch a skate company with
a particular logo image and our coffee
shops as well as some other really cool
stuff that we'll we'll get into in um in
this year so uh you can follow the show
at timcast IRL you can follow me
personally at timcast Andrew do you want
to shout anything out I have like two
minutes of shout outs number one you
were saying about my transformation this
is the book that really did it for me
power of Kabbalah by yehudiburg this
Edition specifically will change your
life answered all the questions I had in
life in the most satisfying way why are
we here where do we come from Incredible
Book I'm leaving this here for Shane
Cashman by the way I think he'll enjoy
it uh this one I'm reading now the ways
of the Saudi camp I recommend this for
Ian actually I'm not leaving you this
this is my copy I'm reading this now but
uh on refining character traits and
maintaining balance in all matters ways
of the Saudi came you have to read this
bro I know you're going to enjoy it
thanks uh Maggie McCarthy and Daniel
McCarthy if people had listened to them
fog City Midge out in Arizona we would
have had legislation that would have
prevented this Kerry Lake Fiasco so uh
Maggie McCarthy fog City Midge I wish
people had listened to her then but
listen to her now she's awesome and uh
my Arizona book is going to feature her
you should check that out my Arizona
book I'm going to have excerpts coming
at the
andrewmeyer.substack.com my website is
the andrewmeyer.com I am banned on
Twitter both before and again with my
burner so Elon Musk put me back uh
unless you want me competing with you on
sub stack bro I know I know you don't
want that competition and uh also
Alpha jerky get the office Tim loves it
Tim Poole loves the alpha jerky at Big
Club usa.com
Jack Links they get their beef from
Brazil this is American beef baby
All-American when you buy from Big Club
USA everything's made in America
everything supports America First
Patriots what's the Tim cast promo code
promo code Tim cast Is that real not yet
but it will be promo code timcast coming
soon if you if you email me and uh the
email and website say I bought it and
I'm I want to use promo code timcast
we'll make sure Tim gets credit it's
good he's eating it right now I mean it
it is there's no sugar it's really
natural stuff no soy no sugar no garbage
is just strong beef and it's stay it's
uh last a year I mean that's what it
says on here best you know eat up by
December of this year that's a long uh
time to stay good with just salt as the
preservative you're gonna love it you
have anything more
any more uh jerky no I think it's your
promotion yeah a couple more couple more
I got I got a long list of credits but
uh yeah shout out to uh old Rose Swig
also banned from Twitter bring back old
row Swig to Elon banned for no reason
another incredible right-wing
entrepreneur the founder of old row he's
helping us out with bigclubusa.com and
uh yeah shout out to Swig he's great uh
he's done millions of dollars of sales
and he's helping us with bigclubusa.com
he's a legend
uh let me let me check my my board of
shout outs oh writtenhousegame.com we're
banned on the Apple Store the first
right-wing video game banned on the
Apple store but available on Android if
you look up fake news turkey shoot cow
ridden houses fake news turkey shoot
we're available on Android
writtenhousegame.com the the first level
is free we're breaking that news apple
is Banning the first right-wing video
game from their App Store we're breaking
that right here on timcast that is news
baby
and uh Andrew you're gonna make me get
out of taser here in just a couple of
seconds here don't chase me bro
anything else
I think that's it the
andrewmar.substack.com I am an amazing
writer you're gonna enjoy it the
andrewmeyer.substack.com Andrew thank
you so much thank you so much for coming
on my website uh youtube.com forward
slash we are change we've been around
for a very long time we really did some
exciting things within the last few
years but we're going to be doing a lot
more exciting things in the future a
person of color coffee butt chugging Biz
coming your way soon youtube.com forward
slash we are change that did a very
interesting video about Russia check it
out right now and uh yeah see you there
youtube.com we are changing if you guys
want to get involved with the foundation
I'm setting up where we're building free
software front-ending uh technology like
like what locals and patreon are doing
but without the middleman where you can
control your own data if you want to get
involved in building this thing with us
hit me up uh we're looking for a UI ux
developer it's not paid yet because
we're still starting the foundation
could be another year before it's up but
if you want to get on the ground floor
start working with us now I'd love to
get involved with some new blood new
people that want to get involved UI ux
hit me up uh someone that knows if
you're familiar with figma design
particularly hit me up on Twitter
um send me a message and I'll get you
involved and also I want to send a
special thank you to my uncle Michael
aylward the lead singer of tin Huey if
you guys know the band been a while
Michael gave me this cool rock he also
finds stones and it looks like an owl so
thanks Michael that was awesome good
seeing your Christmas man
Serge I love you hey what's up at
surge.com everywhere A good episode
usually fun I'll be in the comments
again as usual thanks for joining us I
appreciate it it's uh been cool I was
also going to ask you about the little
Kabbalah bracelet because that's like a
thing you wear if you're part of it this
is the red string we literally wrap it
around the tomb of Rachelle in Bethlehem
and do a special prayer called the Anna
Baka while we're doing it and it imbues
you with the power to repel an evil eye
you know people not everybody out there
has best intentions for you they say
like if uh you're a woman you get
pregnant don't tell people for at least
three months if you have good news in
your life don't tell people because not
everybody has good intentions for you
the red string is to prevent evil eye
right on interesting thanks cheers all
right we'll see you all over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out later